I don't know why Joe Biden did this
interview on 60 Minutes but uh he must
have thought it was a good idea and they
were talking real slow everybody thinks
the interview was for 70 year olds and
amino disrespect to older people but it
was a 60 Minutes interview it was on TV
and they did talk very slow in it Joe
Biden wow there's a variety of just
crazy stories one when asked if his
brain worked he garbled incoherently and
he said something like I don't think
about how old I am then fly and it's
like
I don't know what you're trying to say
dude if you're trying to explain that
your brain works you're not doing it
very well he said that the U.S would
intervene with the military to defend
Taiwan which the White House then for
the fourth time I believe walked back
those claims like I don't even know who
sets policies to the White House anymore
because the White House and Biden
clearly disagree after four times you'd
think that would be the U.S policy but
apparently it's not and the big news is
that Biden has declared the pandemic's
over now of course many in the media
rushed into sang he he didn't he didn't
explicitly say oh he says he believes no
Biden said the pandemic is over and
that's huge because we've already got
issues pertaining to you know they're
saying like oh no the midterms aren't
going to be wrapped up in a single day
because of mail-in bouts end them all
pandemic's over we don't need that
anymore people should start filing
lawsuits saying like it's got to go back
to the Constitutional system Joe Biden
said it twice the pandemic was over he
expressly he explicitly stated
everybody in the in the armed forces
should be able to should no longer be
required to get the vaccine vaccine
mandates should all be done vaccine
passports Biden said pandemic's over
they don't want to admit it they don't
want to accept it because uh they need
it so that's where we're going but my
friends we'll talk about all that before
we get started head over to let me
actually put this in here stronger bones
and life.com and pick up your ageless
multi-collagen from biotrusting you'll
get 51 off this is great stuff you need
it for your joints your hair your skin
your nails and I was just skating
earlier today my knee has actually been
hurting so I needed to to up my my
dosage of the Ageless multi-collagen
head over to strongerbones in life.com
you'll get a 60-day money-back guarantee
and the healthy aging support of
collagen in its ideal forms you really
do want to make sure you're getting the
stuff because I can really tell when I'm
skimping on it and then like it just
starts to hurt you'll get the five key
types of college you need from four
different sources hydrolyzed collagen
peptides meaning better and faster
digestibility to support maximum
benefits for every order today BioTrust
will donate a nutritious meal to a
hungry child in your honor through their
partnership with no kidhungry.org to
date BioTrust has provided over 5
million meals to Hungry kids please help
them hit their goal of 6 million meals
this year their collagen is non-g emo
and free of artificial colors flavors
preservatives and sweeteners it's free
of gluten antibiotics and rbgh and rbsd
nearly no odor or taste known like bone
broth there's no clumping you'll get
free shipping with every order free VIP
live health and fitness coaching from
BioTrust team of expert nutrition health
coach and health coaches for life with
every order and their free e-report the
14 foods for amazing skin with every
order my friends you gotta support
companies that support us and BioTrust
as you know there they they sponsor the
show every month more than once and just
make sure you're giving your money to
people who like you and want your
business so check out strongerbones in
life.com but don't forget to also go to
timcast.com become a member
support our work directly we're going to
have a members only uncensored show
coming up tonight at about 11 pm as we
do Monday through Thursday but as a
member you'll you will also get access
to the cast Castle show as well as Tales
from the inverted world and we've got
more shows coming more members only
content the plan is to rapidly expand
but we can only expand as quickly as we
bring on new members to watch the new
content so it's a process it is it is
what it is it is what it is so uh become
a member smash that like button
subscribe to this channel share share
the show with your friends joining us
today to talk about all of the news and
more is Daniel Turner it's great to be
back Daniel Turner power of the future
hi everyone I was at a conference this
weekend and honestly about nine people
stopping like I've seen you on Tim cast
I watch all the time so it's always
great to see how big your audience is
and to see uh that people think I'm part
of it so thanks for having me here part
of the show I know it and I have to if
your knee hurts my knees killing me do
you mix it with water well yeah you put
in whatever I like putting in smoothies
it's great I'm totally it adds like a
kind of creaminess to it I'm buying it
love it so great to be here thanks
thanks for having me we also got the
T-shirt salesman who lives in the
parking The Humble t-shirt salesman and
even though Joe Biden declared that the
pandemic is over there still is a very
dangerous media virus out there and you
could do your part to fight it right now
with ideas that cannot be censored on
the bestpolitical shorts.com which of
course is represented by the shirt I'm
wearing right now declaring that the
media is the virus and I think when you
look at the fact that they have on
everyone I think there's a solid
argument there in how are you doing are
you working out with me tomorrow Friday
I am tomorrow you're doing kickboxing I
may join you I'm definitely going to
join you and Eyeball this thing dude I
gotta I love your shirt thank you the
media is virus because a virus is just
basically a like a mechanism to transmit
something it's it's you can have viruses
that don't hurt you you can have viruses
that damage you and the media also is a
neutral you know
the corporate media is a very dangerous
very bad virus that destroys the
Integrity of humanity Tim cast is a
corporation we can't we can't debate
this early in the show we can we do it
hey what conference were you at Daniel I
was a Texas youth conference and so it
was a gathering of aimed towards young
people yeah like high school college age
um
you know definitely center right in
nature not not partisan but but
political and I talked about energy and
climate change and energy issues and I
was excited to go because the the 15
year olds the 17 year olds are the one
who've been told their entire life
they're going to die from climate change
yeah you're putting me at ease about
fracking a little bit so it's nice to
nice to hear that it's not necessarily
the end of the world it was like I was
told it was hey Lydia what's happening I
am getting my cast off tomorrow I've
never been more excited delighted to
have you back Daniel let's get into
tonight's topic I love that your cast is
black in honor of her majesty I'm
wearing black issues and of course is of
course um you don't want to know my
opinion you know normally I know
normally in pastels
all right let's read this story from CNN
Biden's comments about pandemic widen
Public Health split over how U.S should
respond to covid-19 I love this they say
even as the U.S prepares for a potential
winter surge of covid-19 President Biden
roamed the cavernous Halls of the
Detroit Auto Show for an interview on
cbs's 60 Minutes and gesturing to the
mostly massless attendees told the
nation the pandemic is over we still
have a problem with covid we're still
doing a lot of work on it he told Scott
Pelley but the pandemic is over he
repeated let's give a round of applause
to everybody yeah it's all over okay
everybody can go home or or leave your
home because the pandemic's over it's so
crazy to me to hear to hear this and
then you know I go out and I still see
people wearing masks in places that
don't require them yeah they must not
know that the pandemic's over yet maybe
maybe they needed this maybe maybe now
Joe Biden's sweet Whispers will uh wage
their fears it will a lot of people wait
unfortunately for better for worse they
wait for the official word and this is
the most official word you're gonna get
anything Biden says is the top official
in the United States well I wouldn't
worry about what the top official says
since last year they were saying that
there was going to be a severe winter of
illness and death and they were
absolutely wrong about it I was on this
show last year and I said kovid's over
it's it's done with there's no way you
could return I was looking at the data I
was looking at the graphs and and that
absolutely happened all the restrictions
and when I mean coven when I mean this
kind of uh Health mandates and these
emergency issues all of that made
absolutely no sense and we have slowly
seen them dwindle because everything
that they promised that was going to
happen with this virus last winter never
happened and this thing was very
interesting because there wasn't a
speech there wasn't an official
declaration there wasn't a parade there
wasn't even a banner it was Joe Biden
walking through a car show nonchalantly
talking to a TV show that aired his
comments five days five days later
saying Cove is over yeah which is
absolutely crazy the one thing that the
article gets right is that it said it
will be a seasonal you know the winter
is coming and and it is seasonal the flu
it has a season lice cases go up in
September because all the kids are back
in school so when they're like well
we're headed towards a season of covid
it's like yeah we're also headed towards
the season of colds and a season of flu
because a lot of our illnesses are
seasonal let me let me read this quote
quote in a week that's Twin Towers right
it's a 9 11 week after week after week
said uh said Greg gonzalves an
epidemiologist at the Yale School of
Public Health
I just want to point out that people die
from like congenital heart failure and
from peanut allergies and other things
and it seems like the a covidian that's
the word right it's like a cult almost
these people are like hyper focused on
one thing it's like Bro Look at flu
deaths right I think they're about
probably half or so but if you're really
saying it's a 9 11 every week okay look
at car accidents like how many car
accidents are there every week so I want
to look it up yeah my point is you're
only talking about one thing Are We
Really Gonna shut down the world because
there's a thing that causes people to
die that's 107 000 people overdosed on
fentanyl last year and divided by 52
weeks that's 2057 per week so you know
that that's another thing that would
that is that is a twin towers every week
how many car accidents per year I've got
38 800 per year so what is that 38
000.50 was it two
um 107 000 died of just just fentanyl so
we're looking at 746 deaths a week in
2019 from car accidents in the United
States what about like heart failure I
think the number one cause of death yeah
heart disease heart disease huh heart
disease so we got we gotta shut it all
down you know we gotta we do that and
well no we gotta do it again heart
disease and to shut down the world for
heart disease being shut down the gym
right shut down all the gyms
and make them make them order Uber Eats
no I get it it's contagious once per day
so it looks like covet is about seven
times as many uh deaths as there were
car accident deaths uh but what about
heart failure heart disease I'm still
looking for that what about obesity how
many people die every year from obesity
I think that that's not ever really the
cause it's that'll bring on something
else that will kill you yeah and it
tends to be a comorbidity
cancer deaths per year
300 000 people die every year due to
obesity whoa wow and it's an epidemic
they say obesity
76 000 a day six hundred thousand die of
cancer every year in America whoa I
gotta say we had Drew Pinsky on the show
last Friday and he's a you know a doctor
Dr Drew and was talking about paxilvid
and how people are having not
breakthrough cases but uh rebound cases
which I think I don't know exactly what
a coveted rebound case is are you guys
it's on you test negative and then you
test positive again so I think obesity
yeah I'm sorry is that covid is still
here like I can feel it I can feel my
back in the same place where I got
really sick before I can see that it's I
can still sense it but I have an
immunity built up now to it oh so you
know it's gonna be here like the flu
virus obesity is two 911s per week
apparently now we are going to be
measuring deaths in 911s because that's
what and I I know it's like it's kind of
silly but they've been doing that since
the beginning of coven like when covid
deaths were really high they were like 9
11 every day and it's like this is a
unit of measurement I think Bill Maher
made a joke about it yeah like are we
using as a unit of how many reichstags
it's because you can point to the 911
people and see who supported them who
sympathizes with them and if you don't
believe in covet and if you don't
believe in vaccines and if you don't
believe in masking so you're you support
the terrorists and and in 9 11 and for
those of us who who remember when all
that happened were you even born with 9
11 to happen when 9 11 happened if you
were like well I think this is
ridiculous I was like oh so you want the
terrorists to win huh it's like no I
don't want the terrorists to win I just
don't think this is the right approach
well the CNN had a Ticker on their show
The Producers were celebrating and happy
that the numbers were going up because
of the more death the more fear the more
viewers that they had and this was
released by project Veritas I know
essentially they loved that ticker they
loved those numbers they loved
celebrating death and they loved the
trauma because essentially what we're
dealing with when we're dealing with
corporate media is a lot of trauma-based
mind control and this is again a lot of
sensationalism a lot of uh you know Doom
and Gloom a lot of severe winter illness
of death none of that happened they were
absolutely wrong this this statement is
very convenient right before the
midterms and I think that has a lot more
to do with it than actual science that
was again bastard from the very
beginning remember a lot a lot of people
pointed out including this show right
after Biden was inaugurated how the the
the CNN ticker death thing disappeared
from their screen right that was in the
bottom Chiron for for for a year and
like the week after Biden got in I was
like yeah we don't need to put that
number anymore even though more people
yeah even though more people died under
Biden which is a silly statistic right
but but it is a true one you know more
people died under Biden with covet than
under Trump but they were like ah we
don't need to talk about statistics
anymore that's important you said with
covet and we we're gonna have to
continuously remind people that there's
a difference between dying with covid
and dying from covid because if you get
into a car accident and you had covet in
your system you might die with covid
from a car accident but they'll still
clock you as a covet death because you
have covet in your system as opposed to
covert making you cough up blood no head
and they're like what did he die of that
if covet no he doesn't have a head they
would say he died with kovitz
what was the cause which is very very
you know that's that's malicious in my
opinion to say the driver
the passenger was bifurcated right down
the middle buddy so there were two covet
deaths because each half had covet we
found we found two income the head was
not wearing a mask
from this last three years I'm just
still in oh shock and awe man this is
like our eulogy for the pandemic yeah
because I I you know these these uh
covidian people they won't they don't
want to give it up they love being the
Karens wearing the mass screaming at
people they do shrieking but it's done
it's been done for a while but this is
it Joe Biden came out and said it that's
what we need now do you find there's
still people who are facing mandates
lockdowns things like that restrictions
it's time to start filing lawsuits do
you absolutely absolutely they're still
they're still teachers being fired today
today 850 unvaccinated teachers and and
Paras were fired from the New York City
education system uh there's still an FDA
emergency authorization for a boost
booster that was just tested on eight
mice there's still people losing their
jobs within the military because they
didn't comply with these mandates which
are which are absolutely nonsensical so
people are still being fired by this why
when the President says it's over Ian
you mentioned that people don't die of
obesity they die from something because
obviously that's called the comorbidity
and people are pointing out that's
literally how they Define covet deaths
as like people get sick and then they
die from comorbidities like was it like
90 some odd percent of people had some
kind of comorbidity and obesity was a
large component of huge so here's the
important factor is that obesity deaths
and covet deaths I imagine have a large
overlap yeah and and age also and then
they started hiding that data how many
people were over the age of 75 and it's
tragic right we don't want our old
people to die people forget the original
reason why the vaccines were rushed is
because it was supposed to save old
people and then for some reason it went
to let's get all the seniors vaccinated
to now you have to get your 15 year old
kid vaccinated I was like what I thought
this was for old people and the old
people if you look at it didn't have
battery actions as much to the vaccine
because it was made for old people but
for some reason it disappeared like that
that thinking of I remember my parents
were happy because they were the ones at
risk dude the idea of vaccinating you to
keep Luke healthy is insane absolutely
it's like we live in the Middle Ages and
there's no and we're all like got
bacteria eating our skin alive then
maybe we would consider that I do want
to point out I think people need to
understand the the full context of what
happened inside of the pandemic
after a while we started seeing
different strains you know we get to
like I'm a crown or whatever and it's
getting weaker and it's weaker it's like
people need to understand the alpha
strain was really scary the the scar
tissue and damaging people's lungs we
had Dr giron you mentioned the spike
protein was was causing microvascular
damage and then it was inhibiting
nutrients and you know oxygen stuff to
get into parts of the body in the early
days of covet you could see the scans of
people's lungs it was really really bad
that's kind of you know yeah I don't
know I think we got Omicron is that what
we got when we got sick
there was also a lot of malpractice
inside of the hospitals that were doing
things that they later found out was
absolutely wrong especially when it came
to drugging a lot of the patients and
then giving them particular medicines
are you talking about malpractice or are
you saying error
um you could I don't know how you want
to I guess categorize it but but there
was a lot of mistakes made early on in
the hospitals that's what I mean to say
like we didn't know what we were doing
like
there's a difference between a doctor
screwing up and us being like this is
the best thing we could think of yeah
but I got I gotta say like I think
policy wise there's a total abject
failure but I thought you should have
been fired immediately that's Trump's
fault but any criticism was
automatically censored any anyone
speaking up was automatically shut down
and there was practices that were done
that that people saw as a mistake
especially when it came to the
ventilators people were saying hey maybe
we shouldn't be doing this maybe we
shouldn't be uh you know knocking
patients out and giving them drugs that
give them organ failure so their bodies
can't fight it off maybe we shouldn't be
incubating them and and that was a big
argument that should have happened
publicly but it didn't and the policies
continued on to the detriment of a lot
of early patients and let's let's talk
about the big change in the and the big
funny news we got the story from
Business Insider moderna bioentec and
novovax plunge after Biden says the
covid-19 pandemic is over whoops yeah
who where those put options at who's
who's waiting for this moment
Paul Pelosi the reason why they waited
five days to air it is because they had
a call all there like hey everyone
probably Dan Crenshaw sell your stocks
absolutely I mean yeah because because
those folks knew this was but this is
this is an important story The New York
Times did actually a good job they
investigated uh the the invent the
Investments of of Congress members and
they reported out of 3 700 trades they
made over a hundred million dollars with
many of them with uh being almost
perfectly timed so the New York Times
actually did a good job investigated and
showed the insider trading that is
absolutely too good to be true for a lot
of these Representatives this Congress
that got rich off of these stocks so
this aired September 18th and it was
filmed when he went there which was on
Tuesday so we need to investigate Who
Sold stocks between September 13th and
September 18th especially these three or
any of the pharmaceutical companies and
it would be fascinating to then have a
legit investigation to say Congressman
Crenshaw how did you know to sell all of
your moderna on Friday before he just
closed we don't know we actually is just
using a name Congressman Turner I'll
call myself there as a congressman
Turner Congressman Cortez how did you
know about it how did how did you know
that would be a fascinating study
because someone made money I'm willing
to bet you'll find a lot of people so
what I would imagine would have happened
is that CBS probably did something they
mentioned in the interview they
contacted the White House for comment
remember that right when Biden when
Biden mentioned that we would intervene
for Taiwan and we'll get to get to that
in a bit they said in the video they
released after Biden gave this response
we reached out to the White House who
said the policy is has not changed
despite the commander-in-chief saying it
did which means
they did the interview
they then called politicians for
comments edited the interview then put
it up how much you want to bet after he
said the pandemic was over they they
called all it takes is one member of
Congress they call Pelosi like what do
you think about this as the speaker and
she went oh is that what he said I'll
call you back and then she's like Heidi
you need to sell all of this facts
before the interview comes out and then
Paul does it and then everyone watching
the Nancy [ __ ] stock tracker sees it
and yeah it's down 10 from the 16th to
the 8th to the 19th the Nvidia moderna
okay since they announced well that's
the one that Pelosi graphics card uh
that was the company with the Pelosi's
the Pelosi insider trading one yes that
one also when they sold it off was also
at a very good time because the stock
went down there was another piece of
news that came out against Nvidia which
you were describing before which I
thought Ian was talking about yeah that
he sold surprisingly he knew to sell
right right before this exactly people
were saying he only sold because he
wanted to be ethical and wanted to come
clean but but he actually sold on it on
a good time which actually gave him even
more money but you guys understand too
is we often talk about how it's inside
of trading because they know when to
sell right how often do they propose the
bills themselves to shift the market
like you could have you know a new
computer chip and then they're like this
new computer chip is gonna be bad for my
stock let's put a bill forward that will
stop it and give some BS reasons yeah or
how often it's like hey I just bought a
whole bunch of Ben and Jerry's stock or
I guess what is it Unilever and uh I
want to go up so we're going to do the
tax ice cream text break stock that
would be intentionally pushing a bill
forward to make their stocks go
absolutely really definitionally fascist
they probably do it all the time should
be felonious yeah I know but that's but
how can you prove it well the New York
Times actually found out that it was the
committee members using their position
on the Committees in Congress that voted
on particular aspects that changed the
business landscape that were enriching
themselves the most look at the
inflation reduction act that we just
passed in 386 billion dollars goes
towards the investment in Green Tech
that anyone who voted for that in
committee and who appropriated that
number do they have a stock in any these
green companies they have stock in in
SharePoint which makes electric chargers
they have stock in in GE which makes a
lot of our wind turbines I mean it's
just if you're going to spend 386
billion dollars someone is going to make
a lot of money off of that and didn't
they make a bunch of money off the
pharmaceutical companies like oh no
absolutely sure the pharmaceutical
industry created more billionaires than
any other industry within the last few
years but I mean like weren't there like
a bunch of it was a big controversy
wasn't it a bunch of members of Congress
sold their stocks right before covid
Richard Burr the senator from North
Carolina that's why he's not running
again right you got to look at modernist
stock in April of 2020 it was 28 in
April of 21
145 dollars seven seven times and then
it was 450 dollars six months later so I
mean that's what is that a 20 times
increase in like a year and a half this
makes me angry you know why because I
didn't buy it
Richard burr from North Carolina to 400
bucks Richard burr from North Carolina
was the one who was probably probably
hit the hardest on that I forget who the
Democrat was but he was he's the
Republican he's not running for re-elect
right now he probably could have and
would have sailed but for this but he
was one of the ones that they said you
had in a skiff which no secure
compartmentalized you know the secret
room to have these confidential meetings
in a skiff you had this briefing that
same day you bought all the you made all
these purchases and all these sales and
just like I you know what so what's the
charge and he just played innocent and
some people and people like you Luke
made a big deal out of it and then he
decided Well I'm not going to run for
re-election next year but there are a
lot of senators who you can point to the
timeline and say you were in This
Confidential briefing and you either
sold in time because remember this is
this is February of 2019 the market the
20th of February of 2020 the markets
were roaring and it's like but suddenly
the markets are exploding and you sold
everything five million dollars worth of
stock and the doj drops their
investigation into all these people
which is absolutely crazy and they and
they start investigating Trump
supporters look actually I think I think
it was fairly obvious the vaccines were
were gonna just Skyrocket and stock
value but you have to be someone who's
not only in the know news wise you have
to have the money and you have to be
knowledgeable in this market space yeah
so even though we all were tracking the
news and knew about the vaccines and
stuff I'm not a day trader I don't know
well that's why Rand Paul is always
beating up fauci to say why don't you
have to disclose your royalties and the
answer is Senator we don't have to
disclose that and I don't have to tell
you
yes and Rand Paul is like you don't have
to disclose to Congress what your
royalties are so you know who in the CDC
made a lot of money off of this because
they knew when they were going to
approve a vaccine if you're if you're a
Tim pool vaccine approver and you're
like we're gonna give these guys the
green green light on Friday maybe do you
buy some stock on Thursdays and when you
see it hit its top these stocks they
they rocketed to like 20 times their
value in March of 21 and then within
like
20 days they just plummeted so somebody
was holding some people and they made 20
times their investment and then just
sold out on the market and what's great
is that they dropped and they bought it
back up what corrects me up is that the
members of Congress who do this then
hold that guy uh Martin scholarly farmer
bro and they were like how dare you how
dare you look at yourself and I'm like
you should have been like have you all
looked in a mirror how much did you guys
made during the covid pandemic right
yeah it's a shame oh it's absurd it's
just it's criminal it's it's God they'll
tell you that this is the whole reason
they run for office about a lot of
people they're like you get in you get
them inside of trading you get out
you're rich for Life Paul Pelosi and and
some members of Congress they're better
stock Pickers than Warren Buffett they
are why would they are on Wall Street
yeah go go work for an investment house
I mean you're that good and if you have
an account on social media that that
documents all the trades and and gives
the The Peasants advice you get censored
your account's gonna take it down which
has happened to a number number of
individuals that literally created
accounts about the the trading of Nancy
Pelosi which has a better track record
than all the other big stock guys out
there better than Warren Buffett better
than all the top guys that you could
even imagine in this field how is that
possible yeah it's amazing shout out to
my homies at Rumble they just went
public today Tim told me earlier and uh
well they closer I bought Rumble stock
I'm not an investment man
so it was a SPAC acquisition
cfvi I think merged with Rumble and now
they're trading under our um well was I
don't play inside games I'm just letting
everyone know ahead of time I did buy
some of that because I have faith in the
future of Rumble how about a bunch yeah
I don't know if that's necessary to
disclose at all basket full of Rumble
stuff I think there's nowhere to go but
literally like right before the show I
was just like yeah it's the future Chris
pavlovsky knows what he's well he's got
a lot of good good ideas and I'm I'm
really excited to see what they do I
mean and for locals gaming too I'll put
it this way I'll put it this way
um you know we we we're in the know when
it came to what was going up the news
and we saw that the vaccines were coming
we knew who was making them and I don't
think anybody here bought any stock in
those companies no no and I don't think
I would have morally no hell no no I
bought stock in palantir and I didn't
know much about it but my body was like
it's about to Skyrocket so I bought it
and then it went up times 10 and I sold
it all I remember I I sold all of my um
Airline stocks when I was I was doing
the TV show Kennedy on Fox the night
president Trump announced that he was
Banning air traffic from Europe and I
remember thinking I'm going to sell all
my Airline because I just had a feeling
this was going in the wrong direction
and so like yeah so I made a great
decision but but I probably was three
days late I'm sure that a lot of people
who were in that confidential meeting
they sold their Airlines
before this is what I wanted to say
about the modern stuff is we're in the
know on the news yet we didn't buy any
of that stuff we're in the know on big
tax censorship and social media and now
Rumble is trading I think at like 16
bucks so that's my attitude was like I I
think it's it's I don't know if it
spikes like 400 anything crazy like that
because it's not a mandated vaccine or
anything but I I bought a bunch because
I think it'll go up yeah it's a company
I believe in that's why I bought it yeah
I don't I don't like one of the things
about finance that I really don't like
is that you kind of need to set your
morals and ethics aside if you want to
make money and you just know if the war
machine's going on that Raytheon is my
man for now and then I'm gonna sell it
and buy Pfizer and then I'm out of there
I'm gonna buy some oh oil and get a
fracking I was gonna say because I'm
programmed to hate this stuff hey check
uh someone check check the stock on like
Raytheon or Lockheed when the Ukraine
war started what February yeah I bet
it's I bet it spiked right sure it did
but it probably it probably doesn't have
as much room to grow because it's
already a massive you know military
industrial where do we go hot in in
Ukraine oh yeah we just hit exactly
right Tim it went from at the end of
December it was 82 bucks is 102 by March
so up up 20 what's it at now right now
it's sitting at about 88. come down a
little come down come down but when the
war starts but that's what was that
Raytheon yeah yeah but are we using what
about Boeing or like Lockheed Martin
what's another was it was another one
north of Grumman north of Grumman
Boeing's actually been up and down and
then dropped in May Boeing's biggest
Money Maker is uh Airlines airplanes
right and the airplane industry is just
getting crushed but they're doing the oh
that's probably why even if they make
drones or whatever we also have to
understand normal people Northrop
exploded in March it went from 369 to
450. 480. how many billions have we
given them in in war and uh you know
Warheads wow and it's just gone up since
then it's at 485 now wow who should we
declare war on next right to get more
money
I don't care who just let me know but in
advance
that's all that matters but but you
again you won't have an advantage like
the politicians have and normal people
when they do insider trading they get
arrested they faced real prosecution
they face the the justice system going
down breathing down their necks and
putting them in jail going down I was
like where are you going
straight yeah get your hand out of it
she's a billionaire she went to jail for
six months absolutely 75 000 trade yeah
why aren't these Congress members who
are aren't these Senators is it because
of their insider trading and then we
also have to understand how nasty this
is especially when it comes to so many
people struggling financially this is
this is a game there's winners and
there's losers they rig the system so
they are always the winners who's the
losers everyone else all the other
peasants the people who have their
retirements accounts in the stock market
that of course are guaranteed to lose
because these people are rigging the
game for the benefit of themselves so so
this is absolutely seedy disgusting
Behavior especially when it comes to so
many people being poor so many blue
collar workers being screwed over and
these people are enriching themselves
while taking money away from everyone
else do you think the lottery is like
unethical uh yeah because most of that
money goes to the state and it's and
it's taxed and absolutely yeah I think
yeah the tax like what like half almost
almost half of it so you're literally
financing the state through the lottery
they call it a poor tax yeah it's a
gambling and then you know if a hundred
bucks going to the pot 50 bucks goes to
the government the 50 bucks goes to the
Jack you know the jackpot and then you
pay taxes on that even yeah like the
person who won the 1.2 billion dollars
who still hasn't come forward which is
odd
um I think they were taking home at the
end of the day like 400 million which is
nothing to sneeze at but basically
governments stole 800 million dollars
from that person but then you got to pay
taxes so it's like it's not only is the
is the is the pot split between the
person and the and the government's cut
but then the the money you get actually
gets cut again yeah it's money how that
works so of the 1.2 was 2.4 half of it
had gone to the government and they're
getting taxed another 60 or 70. that's
why they were walking away with 400
million because 1.2 right off the bat
you know
um half of it goes to education and then
you have half and then your half gets
cut in half by taxes I don't like like
saying like this should be illegal this
should be illegal but that Lottery has
really always set me really really let's
get back to the 60 Minutes interview we
have this uh this tweet here from Benny
Johnson
what do you think of people who say you
are unfit for the job of President Biden
says watch me the proof of the pudding
is in the eating now this is a real
quote and I think younger people just
don't know it because we go by the
shorter the proof is in the pudding but
the actual old idiom I guess is as Biden
expressed it but it's not it's not just
that I want to I want to play for you
this clip and then we will we will roast
Joe Biden you are the oldest president
well let's turn that down a little bit
there you go shouldn't ever pretty good
shape huh no which leads to my next
question you are more aware of this than
anyone
some people ask whether you are fit for
the job some people and when you hear
that
I wonder what you think
watch me
and maybe honest to God that's all I
think watch me if you think I don't have
the energy level of mental acuity then
then you know that's one thing that's
another thing of just watching and you
know keep my schedule what do what I'm
doing I think that uh you know I don't
want to sit down with our NATO allies
and keep them together I don't have them
saying wait a minute how old are you
what do you what they say you know I
mean it's a matter of you know that old
expression the proof of the putting is
in the eating I mean I I respect the
fact that people would say you know
you're old and but I think it relates to
how much energy you have and whether or
not the job you're doing is one
consistent with what any person of any
age would be able to do how would you
say your mental focus is
oh it's focused
I say it's I think it's I I haven't look
I have trouble even mentioning even
saying to myself my own head the number
of years I know more think of myself as
being as old as I am than fly
I mean it's just not uh he is fly what
did he just say why okay he said I have
trouble even mentioning saying to myself
the number of years in my head yep the
number of years of what what's he
talking about how old he is I can't
believe I'm 75 he wanted and then he
says I know what does he say I don't
think of myself as old as I am then fly
then fly at the very beginning he's like
so people think you're old and he was
like looking pretty good huh and then
Scott Pelley just looks away he can't
even look him in the eyes when he says
it oh my God maybe she's stuck in the
80s he's like I'm pretty fly it's like
well we stopped saying that when like
Marky Mark stopped rapping this was by
now it's like full defense mode he's
whining he keeps talking like this if I
talk to you guys like this look it would
sound like I was trying to hide
something if I always talk like this
if somebody if I was sitting down with
an interviewer and they were like Tim
some people think that you are unfit to
host the show I'll go why
well here's what they said I'm like oh
okay well I disagree I don't know what
else you want me to say yeah the fact
that Biden gave all of these answers
shows that he knows exactly what his
problems are and he has to try and
address them in a way or counter them
because the reality is he knows exactly
why people are saying it thus he gave
this long-winded drawn-out wishy-washy
response that ultimately ended in
nonsense yeah but look at how polite
that he gets the open-ended question
like some people are saying this you
know how does that make you feel what
would you say in that if it was someone
who Scott Pelley didn't like it would be
like why should we believe you when you
think when you say you're healthy enough
to be president like why why should we
trust that you have the mental acuity
like it would be so much more defensive
so much more attacking but with Biden
it's this open-ended how does that make
you feel he says do what I do like are
you are you telling the people who think
you're unfit to be it's not for
president to copy your schedule and see
if they can do it yeah
this is him also allegedly being drugged
up because there's some sources there's
some rumors out there that he's being
fed a hole but bunch of drugs right
before these interviews and then the
interviewer here is still not doing his
job like you counter be like sometimes
five right now talk
it just look shocked and like explain
yourself more here because this
absolutely makes no sense at all and if
there ever was an argument that there's
a shadowy secretive government ruling
things behind the scenes this is it
right there okay I just just because I
recently finished watching Breaking Bad
that the instant joke I get is that
there should we should do a gag where
it's this interview and then it like
cuts to uh slightly behind the scenes
with Walter White being like get it
right
meth this is um Biden got these
questions ahead of time and then I
assume they do all the time and then CBS
sent this interview to the White House
before they aired it to make sure
everything was clear if the interviewer
had actually been like okay you're
saying you're fine I'm watching you walk
around the Oval Office and you're you're
shuffling left and right and looking
like an old man they would have been
like interview's over get them out of
here and they wouldn't have run it if
this was a real interview the interview
would have been like you're kidding me
right like you're joking right look at
the Leslie stall interview also 60
Minutes of President Trump how hostile
it was how nasty I mean it was it was a
vicious interview because she hates him
and they let their true colors fly I
tweeted this earlier today Daniel Turner
power of the future Daniel or BTF on
Twitter I tweeted this earlier today if
you were the President's White House
comms team and it's been 210 days since
he's done an interview and you're like
holy crap we got to break the streak
they chose 60 Minutes in Scott Pelley
for a reason and it's not because
they're top-notch journalists they
wanted softballs this is what people
need to understand stand too these
interviews have always been selectively
edited yeah always I love how they like
to rag on Project Veritas like the
videos that selectively edited and it's
like they're doing an undercover
operation I do think in many
circumstances James should publish the
raw archives be like here's our
editorial like that we published here's
the raw footage make up your own mind I
thought why the most but this these
interviews since the Inception of 60
Minutes have always been edited and
people don't understand that I guarantee
you he's he asks a question there are
certain points in the interview because
I watched it where you'll it'll it'll
it'll show Joe Biden talking and then
it'll cut to Scott Pelley like just like
shaking instead of nodding that's a
trick so they can edit the audio of
Biden without making it seem like they
did an edit because they get a they get
a still shot of a solid 30 seconds of
Pele but then they take two 45 second
bidens mash them together and put his
video over it so you don't see it
jumping thank you for bringing that up
especially when you ask them about
Taiwan and this is an old thing they
used to do in the 80s too I remember but
I didn't realize it was the media
manipulation like you're talking about
till today he asked him would you use
military troops would you put American
troops in Taiwan if China were invaded
and Biden was yes and then Biden starts
to clarify he goes some and then
immediately it edits to Scott Pelley and
his voice talking over Biden's response
to arguably the most important question
ever asked of a U.S president uh in in
the last month or year or whatever of
Our Generation literally going to war
with China and um and it's Scott Pelley
talking over Biden's response you can't
even understand what Biden was saying
and then it cuts back to Biden saying
the end of his response and you they
edited out Biden's response people need
to get this this interview was probably
substantially longer and then way cut
down I guarantee you in this in this
video I'm willing to bet Biden probably
went
what's it what did he was here and
they're like okay we'll cut that out and
then we'll get his answer because here's
what we know
we know that when Biden speaking live he
says things like next now recent bada
calf care true and an unashabad of
pressure Trinity pressure what else has
he said I got those three there's a few
more he says things that make no sense
and he's angry and he gets angry but
here's the important piece
I will listen to Joe Biden and he'll say
something like you know we got a economy
man you gotta just throw it up
strengthen inflation's bed and then
you'll read NBC and it'll say the
president said the economy needs to be
short up at strength because inflation
is getting bad and you're like he did
not say that yeah daily wire took a
great uh you read that one yeah yeah we
I don't even pull that tweet up
and and I I hope I hope that uh um well
I'm glad the daily wire understands this
when you read an article from the daily
wire they quote Biden and it says I I uh
what's it uh you know well the economy
is it dot dot dot and I they put it all
in there yeah here's the quote Biden on
his mental focus oh focused haha I'd say
it's it's it is I haven't here look I
have trouble even mentioning even saying
to myself in my head the number of years
I no more think of myself being old as I
am than fly
that's a literal translation it's like
so yes I'm surprised that the White
House ran that that response that's
insane he's not saying I'm flying no but
that's how I'm interpreting you oh right
I think what he's trying to say is I'm
older than dirt no no he's sang Let me
let me try and give a different sentence
I he say something like I wouldn't do a
backflip as soon as like
he's basically saying to the same degree
of which I fly I think of myself as old
which is not that's weird you know what
I mean oh that's what he's trying to
write exactly exactly and I'm
translating and now Tim Poole translates
Joe Budden what is the point the media
has to try and decode it's like it's
like we're sitting in a bunker with like
a little wheel we're spinning it like
I'm trying to figure out what he's
saying it's like I can't figure it out
can you play the fly part again just the
part where he says I no longer think of
me being focused is
oh it's focused
I say it's I think it's I I haven't look
hold on a minute I'm sorry I got to stop
right there how's your mental focus it's
focused exactly what they jump there's a
cut there there's a cut there hold on
let me let me play the question again
each would be able to do how would you
say your mental focus is
oh it's focused
I believe he said how would you say your
mental focus is there was some kind of
back and forth and then they edited that
response and because it's focused what
did the subject change to when he said
that question because the subject was
Biden he's referring to himself as it or
his mental focus as it no no mental
focus was the subject or he was the
subject so we wouldn't say my if when he
says it he's saying my mental focus is
focused yeah but he was the subject not
the focus you're calling himself it no
they edited something out of there but
let's play more
I said I think it's I I haven't look
I have trouble even mentioning even
saying to myself my own head the number
of years I know more think of myself as
being as old as I am than fly
I think I get it now when he when he
said the years there's a missing context
they edited out a chunk of that you're
right when he said
um I have trouble mentioning saying even
myself the number of years
they must have had a back and forth
following up on what the question was
confusing Biden mentioned something
about well you know you've been in in
for how many years right so you've been
in for 50 some odd years so so how would
you say how would you say it's going and
then well it's focused you know yeah and
and I know more I I have trouble mention
myself the number of years that the
context of where the years fits into
this conversation makes no sense age
it's how long he's been working at this
it sounds like to me it sounds like they
cut out a huge chunk of this and Biden
was probably rambling that's why that's
why the White House okay that response
because it was the best they got out of
that response because how's your mental
focus it's focused it's not something
you want someone to respond it makes no
sense yeah so I don't think I'm too old
to do this job any more than I think I
can fly as like whether he was going to
say something like that or I don't think
um he's saying like I don't think of
myself as he says he's basically saying
I think of myself as old as often as I
fly which is never oh gotcha but but
it's confusing because he flies in
Planes all the time so it's like are you
talking about flapping your wings like
you know when I first heard that I had
to sit down and actually I'm like
looking at the quote the transcript
first you read the transcript and you're
like this makes no sense I have no idea
what he's trying to convey then you hear
him say it and you go
wait hold on when I saw the first
transcript it was t-h-e-n then I saw the
daily wire right t-h-a-n and I'm like I
am I have this guy's out of his family
his thumb fly a thing we don't know
about is there a theme fly is that like
a so it's it's that or them then fly
like he's saying I don't I think of
myself as old as often as I flies now if
he says this and the five of us sitting
around this table who are all fairly
intelligent or struggling the beginning
beginning of his comment he talks about
look when I sit down with the NATO
Partners imagine what they're really
thinking like what are we going to war
like what wait wait he went to the G7
and he said we're going after Libya
Libya Libya and everybody did go what
well when when is this happening oh did
he mean Syria Syria Libya and I and I I
tell people when when they try and
downplay this stuff the severity of it
is Joe Biden's gonna be in situation
room and he's gonna be like so so give
me the brief and they're going to be
like we've got you know baghdadi we've
got these guys we got this guy here's
the region they're moving in and the
Middle East and North Africa it's it's a
large swath of territory that has
overlap between some of these groups and
is going to go we need to get a missile
strike in Libya and they'll be like the
Libyan Target I'll be like yeah yeah the
Libya and they'll go well the the the
the the the problem is centered over
here and uh I said Libya and they'll go
oh okay all right they'll go to the
generals and be like he wants to strike
and move in on Libya and they're gonna
be like why hmm what nothing's happening
now like this is what he's the
commander-in-chief is ordered now
I don't think they would actually follow
through because I think the White House
has gone Rogue let's jump to this next
story and I'll tell you but I'll wrap up
that thought basically Jill Woodstock
imagine a circumstance where they go you
got a boss and then all of a sudden you
got terrorists outside of Syria and then
Libya is being bombed repeatedly well a
situation like that is like go get them
go kick his door down go to Donald
Trump's house and get blah like these
erratic you know almost nonsensical
moves are like really intense weird out
of the sideways things and they will go
for it sometimes so so you're saying the
raid on Trump was actually it could have
been like an old man Angry it was an oh
won't someone rid me of this priest I
don't know he says he didn't know
anything about it Donald Trump somebody
ought to write his house take some
documents from him go get him I don't
care what about the borders or the means
justify the ends justify the ends so
here's here's where we go check it out
we got this story as an update China
largest complaint after Biden says U.S
could U.S would defend Taiwan in a
Chinese invasion so this is it I'm going
to say this first and foremost the White
House has gone Rogue now I know hold on
we said a long segment talking about how
Biden's brain is completely broken
and so you would assume the White House
must do something to stop a Mad King
right you know like uh was it uh Robert
Baratheon he was the one who slayed the
no no I'm sorry that's not true that was
um it was uh Lannister oh yeah
because the Mad King was nuts and and he
regretted it and he felt bad about it
what is it a.s Targaryen was that his
name I don't know it was the Targaryen
The Mad King and so uh here we have Joe
Biden who I don't think mad is the right
word what's the right word the Daft
deluded
the dotted King and so um the White
House is basically
intervening and rejecting and denying
the stated policies of the
commander-in-chief now here's here's
what I'm going to say the executive
branch has gone completely Rogue I I I
firmly believe that I was thinking about
this day because Joe Biden has now said
four times
it is the U.S policy four times to
militarily defend Taiwan and every time
he does the White House goes actually
that's not true and it's like well I
don't know who the spokesperson is but
the commander-in-chief just went to a
press conference in Tokyo and said we
will and the Pres the president
commander-in-chief just went in 60
minutes and said this is our policy yeah
and when Scott Paoli said you sang the
US Army would defend he goes yes
definitively when the President says it
the duly elected commander-in-chief that
is the policy he sets the policy the
White House intervened and says no it
isn't the doj intervenes they do what
they want look at Donald Trump this has
been happening under Trump and Biden
plain as day the executive branch has
gone Rogue under Donald Trump they lied
to him about the number of troops in
Syria rejecting his orders to get our
troops out under Joe Biden he is stating
definitively over and over again our
policies our position on Putin no they
said that's not true our position on
Taiwan no it's not true if the president
says it you listen who is the person
under Trump and now under Biden who are
the people who are outright saying we
will not listen to the
commander-in-chief yeah no it's it's
more than more than one look at Deborah
Burks right when she was going back to
covid stuff and in her book she talks
about how yeah I wouldn't give Trump
those numbers yeah I wouldn't I wouldn't
share that data like I wasn't going to
share it with them because it would have
screwed everything up so she made the
decision that I don't have to tell the
president so he can make decisions I'm
more powerful than the president and I
think at every policy issue there's
someone who calls those shots but the
clean house has to be huge but there's
no coincidence especially when you look
at the presidency when it changes from
democratic to Republican the National
Security State American foreign policy
usually stays the same it's usually very
hawkish it's very neoconservative it's
very pro-war and it's very
pro-globalization pro-imf World Bank
policies that of course are are
spreading all this globalization around
the world what I think is happening here
if I could put on my conspiratorial hat
is that they literally will bite it in
into an interview which he does very few
of and then they wheel them off after
they take them off all the drugs they
put them at a table just like a Fisher
Price table and it has a button it has a
phone but none of it actually works and
there's people behind the scenes truly
calling the shots just like they do in
almost every other presidency and and
Biden and legitimately legitimately
could be pressing the the nuke button
could be calling people talking to
people but it's all make pretend it's
all it's all make believe it's not real
and the people truly calling them shots
are people who have more power than the
president of the United States and they
probably meet in private organize and
and set policies that of course we've
been following for many decades now that
always go unquestioned that every
president promises to change when he's
going to become president every
president when he runs on that campaign
Trail says I'm going to stop the wars
I'm going to stop the spying I'm going
to bring back American Liberties I'm
going to bring back America and none of
them are able to do it I love the idea
of this is a skit for you Tim I love the
idea of president with his fake phone
his fake buttons that when he calls and
he's like get me the president of France
and it's like do your French accent
French accent it's like a wee Michelle
president this is and then like it can
be Germany it's like who does German who
does German uh this is the German Prime
Minister and she's like this one guy
here
give me give me the president of Germany
and he's like yeah this is President of
Germany why do you sound Russian I did
Russian uh regarding whether or not
assistant president give me the
president of the Congo
what other evidence do you need than the
current president of the United States
to understand that there's a shadowy
secretive group really Kongs the things
behind the scenes what other evidence do
you need is that even a secret it's not
a secret under Donald Trump they
outright lied and blocked him from doing
the things he ordered yeah if I went on
CBS as the president had made a
statement about my political agenda and
then someone in my Administration
countered came out and secretly counted
I'd fire them that that moment you're
fired seriously it's why Trump said he
was going to release the the JFK
documents he didn't do it he couldn't do
it because there was someone above him
said no you're not it's one of the
reasons why I love
um you say yeah what you said blizzard
person no I didn't say yeah to that but
one of the things that one of the
reasons the person I'm most excited
about running profits right now is uh
running in in Washington state Dan
Crenshaw but one of the things that got
him to run was that his wife was in
Syria when they lied about the numbers
I'm sorry Dan Crenshaw
well one is
um wasn't has Joe kid ever been on yes
yeah I wasn't on that shirt and it's
like his his wife was one of the ones
who died because they lied to him when
Trump was like what's going on in Syria
and they were like let's just tell him
this tell him this tell him this they
lie and so Joe Ken is like you got you
guys killed my wife because you're
you're more powerful than president
Trump maybe Bill Gates By the way is
bragging today Bill Gates came out on
MSNBC they were playing a video clip of
him and he says you know the president
of the United States Donald Trump at the
time came to me he asked to be an
advisor I said no and then Donald Trump
asked me if if I needed to do uh
independent Commission on the effects of
vaccines Bill Gates says he told him to
absolutely not to do it not to do it
because it was a quote dead end and the
president of the United States listened
to him and listened to the advice of
Bill Gates and didn't do a commission
and investigation into what's really
happening right now and now the data is
still being hidden away from everyone
with the FDA hiding information about
what actually happened and transpired
within the last few years which is
absolutely crazy yeah and and it's got
to be all financially going back to this
issue of the stocks it's all Financial
incentives it's not just because people
like I believe so passionately about
Syria that I'm gonna lie about the data
it's like no like you're doing this
because you have ulterior motives we've
got
we call it a cult but it's Mass
formation psychosis yeah well here's I'm
looking at the definition of Madness uh
a state of severe mental illness not
non-technical so you could argue that
Biden's in a state of Madness right now
that he's the Mad president uh or a mad
president Behavior thinking that is very
foolish or dangerous yeah but saying
that we're going to invade Taiwan when
apparently the the White House's
statement is invaded Taiwan right right
defend Taiwan send troops there against
the will of the people
um who knows Taiwan wants us if they
want us then it wouldn't be an invasion
but if they didn't ask for it and we
went there to defend democracy then it
would technically be a counter Invasion
unless you think it is China then we are
innovating uh and so apparently the
policy is we're not going to mention it
but he mentioned it anyway so that's a
state of foolish or dangerous thinking I
don't know well look look the the
problem here is
I think a lot of people recognized that
it was dangerous what Biden said that
he's risking World War I think The
Hodgetwins said Grandpa's about to get
us into World War III and I thought
about it I'm like yeah but Trump had
that phone call where he was like they
thought we would nuke them if they took
uh Russia if Russia took Ukraine or
China took Taiwan and he's like no no
they believed me but maybe five percent
so it was enough and I'm like that's
that's crazy and scary but see that's
Trump being like that level of
aggression so my issue here is not that
Joe Biden said we will defend Taiwan I
actually can respect that because when
he was asked about it twice he goes yes
like definitively no question my problem
is somebody in the White House is
defying him and trying to assert some
kind of authority over his stated policy
positions and is super pro-china at this
entire White House is and and I always
have to go back to environmental issues
but if you really want to defend Taiwan
so sincerely from an invasion of China
then you would be seeking policies that
weaken China and yet we're spending 380
six billion dollars to buy solar panels
and wind turbines from China and lithium
battery and lithium exactly our whole
policy is pro-china and we gave them
Afghanistan we literally gave up them a
silver platter and all the raw minerals
as soon as the United States military
left the Chinese uh engineers and the
Chinese companies came right in and now
we're going to be going through a Green
Revolution going to be energy
independent we're not going to be
independent we're just buying lithium
batteries from China China that of
course has record CO2 emissions they're
doing this to help the environment the
environment is going to be screwed over
even more allegedly according to their
own and data and but but what's going to
change is we're going to be investing in
China and China is going to be
controlling our energy sector which is
crazy and we're going to be yeah yeah
and we're removing tariffs from China
yeah if we move away from fossil fuels
and we go towards lithium batteries and
solar panels China essentially will have
a control on the market yeah they don't
have it yet because of fossil fuels uh
the petrol dollar has the control on the
market but China will have a huge
control thanks for the plug Elon also
hasn't mentioned lithium is not the
future of battery power he knows that as
well I don't know the story pulled up
about it graphene maybe yeah I think he
actually has recently been looking into
graphing batteries oh wow yeah graphy
yeah Power of the future with graphene I
was I was when I was in the Texas doing
this youth conference because there were
a bunch of rural folks on that level
American we talked about the Ford F-150
the lightning one and I I just told them
about how in a Wall Street Journal guy
was was driving it with an empty
two-horse trailer and after 100 miles
the battery was dead and I was like how
many of You Haul 15. electric fat the
electric one empty two-horse trailer a
hundred miles dead and I was like how
many of You Haul fifteen thousand twenty
thousand pounds of cattle on a weekly
basis and so you know the so of course
Elon knows the future of lithium is it
doesn't have the horsepower it doesn't
have the strength it doesn't that's why
you know and it's cool and that's why
little duracells are great and that's
why batteries in your iPhones are great
but to compare just the the potential
energy of what is needed to power
elevators and to power airplanes you
know uh just it's well it's nonsensical
and it's moving towards a pathway where
of course they will be limiting people's
movement and that is the end game
towards the Green Revolution that we're
going towards it's it's it's the thing
behind the screen it's behind the cover
that's essentially where we're heading
towards yeah exactly so there's there's
the story that I'm seeing going around
they're saying that uh Ram's gonna drop
the EcoDiesel V6 or whatever
so a lot of people are it's 33 miles to
per gallon it's the ram turbo diesel
three liter v6 or whatever A lot of
people are bringing this up because you
know Ram is going to be moving forward
like an electric truck or some sort but
you were just talking about how it went
100 miles and then died it was dead yeah
so I I mean if you need to haul anything
of weight you're as of now the electric
vehicles can't make it they may
revolutionize electric cars and electric
trucks someday and the future is bright
we may get there but the fact of the
matter is we're not there so if you
think I'm just going to get my electric
truck and do what I do with my fossil
fuel truck you're kidding yourself you
can't haul substantial weight the same
reason why when they said we finally got
this airplane to to fly from JFK to
France on battery power or on on solar
panels I was like yeah it was unmanned
and it had nothing but batteries it was
it was it was it was a a toy you know
you just can't compete with the actual
energy released from the hydrocarbons of
fossil fuels so they're nuclear could
they're saying with uh Motor Trend
writes the 2024 Ram 1500 electric
vehicle is going to get 500 Miles uh to
the charge or whatever 200 kilowatt
hours provide a promise 500 miles of
range and the 800 volt architecture will
speed up the fast charging
yeah I don't I don't think it's going to
work put some weight in it put some yeah
so so people need to understand this too
because you know Luke knows this we have
Teslas you put weight in those things
those batteries go down quick fill the
back of that with a couple round bales
of hay and now do it in in February yeah
especially when it's cold which has a
direct effect on the batteries
they're not thinking they're nothing
Biden money it's all Biden money it's
all investment into foreign globalist
corporations that of course are going to
be giving you a product that doesn't
work half as good that is meant to of
course deny you the ability to move
that's essentially what they're doing
here
electric trucks man is a crazy concept
but I I'm willing about Tesla will do it
better to be honest
yeah they're moving away from didn't
they create like a semi truck uh Tesla
yeah
but they had another big one that's
going to be automated but also the
Automation and the self-driving is also
going to have a huge vast effect on on
Humanity as well fast charging is bad
for the battery yeah it's really bad for
the battery you get warnings Tesla's
only let you charge by default up to 80
unless you manually override and if
you're doing standard charging which is
like 10 10 of the speed then you could
you can go up to 90 but so uh what is it
like what is it what does it add look
like 10 miles per hour or something a
standard Charter I'm not sure the exact
uh I think it's 40. yeah I think because
we've got I've got a Tesla plug and I
think it it gives you 40 miles of range
every hour
so you use that car for one day for
errands and you've got to plug it in for
several hours you go to the supercharger
it'll be done in 20 minutes but it
damages the battery and only it warns
you to only up to 80 percent now imagine
you're in a truck and imagine you're in
a Ram 1500 what how much weight do you
think 1500 normally would would be
Towing oh gosh that thing isn't no more
than four tons I can't imagine four tons
yeah wow I don't think 1500 yeah I don't
think it could but I mean that but I
mean like regularly I mean people in the
chat probably know like what's the
what's the what's the amount of money
probably two tons it depends on the
hardware underneath that we can't even
mention on this YouTube channel
the hardware the hardware underneath the
truck that we can't say on this YouTube
channel what the the get it get a
transmission yes
but no no of course of course but my
question is just like if somebody buys a
Ram 1500 they're not they're not going
to be hauling commercially I mean it's
going to be for what like semi-personal
semi-professional yeah this says here
approximately 990 to 2 000 pounds right
that's it wow yeah that's nothing oh wow
I didn't think it was going to be that
that's a 2014 Dodge Ram okay well that's
old it could probably do way better
these days so if you're getting the
electric one you know they're expecting
to to pull that much if you think you're
getting 500 miles of range on that
battery no and then don't don't expect
to do any like weekend work jobs yeah
because you got to stop that then plug
it in for five hours and don't go up any
Hills how long does it charge don't do
it in winter yeah like if you charge
your battery and you just let it sit how
long does it stay charged
that's a good question on an electric
car I don't know if you if you Tesla
owners if you plug in your Tesla and
it's fully charged and you unplug it and
you just let it sit does it last for a
day two days five days a week I filled
up my gas tank like a year ago and I
haven't moved my car and it's still got
like I hope you well
too and your car battery goes bad as
well yeah the car is totally I think
it's a funk it's just 10 10 to 15 uh per
day depending if you have Sentry mode on
so you lose about 10 to 15 per day and
it's connected to the internet it's got
a sell signal that doesn't get that much
battery at all so uh how would we make a
nuclear power truck how would we do that
that's what I love about Back to the
Future remember he comes back doc comes
back at the end and he's got Mr fission
in the back of the in the back of the of
the of the uh the DeLorean right and
he's putting in all the the food scraps
why why are we not there what if we made
like a nuclear powered steam train you
know well I mean they just put water in
and it just goes the Navy has All
nuclear-powered Ships where nuclear is
not legal for for for commercial or
private use but the military uses it all
all the aircraft carriers submarines are
all nuclear powered why can't if you
want to go on Carnival cruise from here
to Jamaica why can't you take a
nuclear-powered cruise ship okay and
you're like well it's dangerous well you
let the poor 18 year old farm boy from
Iowa get on a nuclear power Germany goes
around the world so I don't know why
they don't all have nuclear power you
wouldn't need that much nuclear material
you know you know they would shovel the
coal make a steam steam engine work yeah
just put you know a couple of nuclear
rods in there and it's good for a really
long time imagine if it's just
remarkably dangerous the size of those
those tankers that bring all of our crap
from China right those things that are
the size of five football fields and
they've got 40 000 can imagine if they
were nuclear powered how much Greener
for the earth to not burn hundreds of
thousands of gallons of diesel but
they're not allowed to be nuclear
powered even in but they go in
international waters what if they made
like nuclear Auto ferries that stopped
before they get to territorial Waters
and then switched they should for some
reason or right now only only military
is allowed to have nuclear powered
usually if you have a little fancy yacht
you should have a bit small nuclear
engine I should have a nuclear reactor
in my backyard you should have one it's
like Fallout your play The Fallout games
that everybody had their cars were
nuclear so in the game they explode
which makes no sense for nuclear power
but no
but people think like Nuke means bombs
so you know exactly it's the exact same
technology also they're little small
except they just build a big wall around
it so the explosions is contained white
power Works
what's the end result of this people
talk about how Tesla cars can be remote
controlled and all that stuff it's like
oh you buy the electric vehicle they're
not gonna let you charge and I'm like
they can just shut your gas station down
like if they can stop you from charging
your car they can just shut down the gas
station I mean if they don't want you
driving you're not driving yeah if the
power goes out of the gas station the
pumps don't work right exactly so people
are like in Californians that don't
charge your electric car and it's like
and well I think the biggest difference
and this is where I agree with you 100
um
for for for good the fossil fuel
industry is still in private hands if
you need gas you're not dependent upon
now your government can shut it down
true but the government doesn't provide
you with gas the government doesn't
produce it they don't manufacture it
they don't refine it it's in the hands
of the private sector the government for
good or for ill I would think for ill
the government does provide you
absolutely the government does provide
your power and so if What charges your
vehicle is gas and it's free or it's
electricity and it's government then
you're in the hands of the government
100 and that is a scary scary Prospect
they're like well I'll just put solar
panels around my house but that you know
the solar does not generate enough
electricity I'm gonna build a sale car
yeah just well they work as well as wind
turbines I'm gonna I'm gonna build a
Flintstone car and then feed all of you
guys uh but but now also another layer
to understand here with smart meters and
and smart grids and smart cities they'll
be able to calculate what you used your
electricity for since everything is
connected to Wi-Fi everything's
connected to the internet and just like
they start denying drones access to
particular territory they could do the
same thing with electric vehicles that
of course have cameras inside of cars
watch your every move and of course
could control and database you on such a
level where you could literally be
brought to a police station if you
commit a a thought crime inside of your
Tesla the Tesla will automatically
snitch on you to the central controllers
the central controllers will literally
drive you to the gulag you don't have
enough credit yeah you have enough
social credit you didn't do enough Good
Deeds no you use too much carbon too
much carbon the end game here is also a
social credit carbon score that of
course the world economic Forum has been
talking about they just released an
article talking about how great was it
for people to be locked down during the
last two and a half years and how that
gives us hope to lock people down for
new social carbon credit score that
they're going to be implementing and it
gives them the possibility to do this as
they were celebrating the previous
lockdowns looking for future lockdowns
that they want to put on you and they
can only put it put them on you if you
of course acquiesce and and comply with
this utter nonsense that they have
already put us through within the last
few well that's why a lot of the greens
keep talking about climate change as a
public health emergency because as soon
as you declare as soon as you compare it
to covid then you can use the same
Protocols of covet and the greens have
wanted to do heck the greens have wanted
to make meat illegal for 40 years right
they want to make the greens are so
envious I wrote an article about this a
couple months a couple of months ago
about covet Envy The Greens look at the
the coveted people and like how did you
guys do this in in in a couple of months
we've tried for 40 years to get people
to not go to church but under covet it
was like oh sorry churches are close you
could go to the liquor store you could
go to McDonald's and you could go to
Walmart just just think about the kind
of person that would try to forcefully
take away your steak Yeah like have you
ever had a good tenderloin
amazing it's beyond meat is just as good
as Bill Gates we also did that freaky 60
Minutes interview where he talked about
how it was just as good with Anderson
Cooper just as good and guess who owns
all like the beyond meat factory freak
Show world or who buys up all the
farmland and says you can't produce cows
anymore and has man bazungas out there
in the general public and it's clearly a
very unhealthy individual then Elon Musk
post a pregnant man meme exactly I made
a t-shirt out of it and it's one of our
best sellers and it's absolutely it's
true I went to the Frederick County Fair
this past weekend
and uh I love the county fairs are
amazing um the Frederick one's really
big because Frederick's like I think 300
000 people are some massive City and uh
they're chickens you get to go in and
there's animals all over and there were
bunnies and the bantams are always just
so funny and they were chickens and the
chickens none of them looked anywhere
near as cool as our chickens for real
like I looked at the brahmas I was like
they got nothing on Siri but for but um
I just think about that how it is not
difficult to have chickens right
even if you want to live sustainably you
get chickens all you have to do is
protect them they just eat they walk
around they eat grass they eat bugs they
eat then there's berries and those other
stuff they just eat all day non-stop you
don't gotta do anything you just fence
them off and make sure nothing kills
them and then the best part is you can
eat their babies like well you can eat
the babies before they're babies you
don't want to eat baby chicks and then
you can eat them when it's time to eat
them why take that away and make us eat
crickets when you can literally just
have the chickens eat the Crickets and
then you get the chicken meat and the
eggs and their feet you can eat all the
chicken parts yeah and then you can even
use chicken bones and whatever for
whatever it is you want to do I don't
know you can make a little car out of
them or something yeah the fascination
with crickets I see all the videos all
the time the images of like all the
cricket snacks all the
um we had uh one of the times I was here
with that that awesome Canadian uh uh
Kian right he's big into all the
different Cricket manufacturers and
cricket and I hope Ian's uh um uh kian's
watching Kian Bexley I follow him on
Twitter have you but he was big into all
the companies that make cricket food
have you have you ever looked at the
sodium levels of fake meat
I was probably through the roof lethal
like it's it's crazy I was looking at I
think I can't remember which fake meat
company it was but the sodium it was
like one burger patty was like 73 of
your daily sodium intake because it
tastes like crap yeah now look I don't
mind some of I don't mind veggie burgers
like a black bean burger can be very
good oh they're delicious quinoa Burger
I've had those are fine I love you know
and it's like it's its own thing you get
you get like a quinoa black bean with
like peas or whatever and then you can
put like onions it's good when it's
meant to be good but sometimes you want
hard protein you want just to get some
protein maybe you're trying to get all
ripped like you know Hemsworth you got
to eat a lot of fish and you gotta eat a
lot of chicken and beef is okay I don't
like to eat too much beef because it's
it's rough it's tough uh chicken and
fish is really really great but they're
taking all of that away why fish get a
pond throw fish in it and then make sure
you're not eating too much of it but
they're literally like despite the fact
that is it easily possible to have have
sustainable farms for yourself and a
homestead they're like no no you should
eat the bugs nothing is better for those
farmers who are watching also than a pig
because the thing eats absolutely the
pig eats the chicken have you ever have
you ever seen a pigs eat everything I
watched a pig eat a chicken bone and it
just shatters that in one bite if you
fall in it and if you fall on a pig
truffle pigs are eating and your hand is
in the way like watch out like they're
they're not to say that they're violent
like that but if they are eating and you
put your hand there like sorry watch
your hand buddy
I'm I want to make a pig horror movie
let's do it we got a budget who wants to
make it I'm sure there's many and it'd
be like like the pigs cometh and it'll
be like a bunch of hogs break out of a
pig farm a bunch of people in New York
state that only have five rounds in
their magazine and then there's like 50
50 Hogs I'm like no no no
girl let's do it let's make a comedy
horror where it's like you find a bunch
of stuff New York and mushrooms a pig a
pig farm just north of New York City
erupts and there's like a thousand pigs
that Rampage the city no one has any
weapons so it's just like geometry oh
and they would they would eat so well in
New York City because there are so many
homeless and drug addicts just like
sleeping on the street no the pigs would
the pigs would they get so fat they
wouldn't be able to be violent after a
while it'd be funny if like we do a
parody film it's like meant to be silly
but then it turns out to be so so good
that it spawns like a an AMC drama
series that lasts like six seasons
becomes like multiple movies in a
universe and it's the pig cometh
he's Australian and uh Australian
Outback your husband and you want to
talk about pigs what are you saying hey
come on no because in the Australia they
hunt wild boar and they would do it for
fun because Australians are all a little
crazy they would do without any any
weapons they would just use dogs and
their dogs were so well trained that
they knew which ear to grab and if they
grabbed the wrong one they would switch
so I'm on the left ear I'm the right ear
and Andrew will tell you if you just get
a pig from the behind any farmer knows
this Pigs Can't turn around you just
have to grab its hind legs and I'm like
so this is a wild pig with two dogs on
its ears and you would describe it's
like yeah you grab its leg and you pull
out your knife in you and he says this
with an Australian accent which I'm not
gonna imitate and you pull out your
knife and you just stab at the neck and
I'm like Australians like crazy
Australians are very weird no a legit I
want to make a pig pig horror movies but
look that's a really good idea the the
conflict should be that people can only
have three rounds in their magazines
and most don't even have guns because
people who live there tend not to like
in New York don't have them and so then
it like the superhero turns out to be
some like he's a big fat redneck guy
with a Maga hat and he's got like a 100
round drum and he's like I'll save you
and then he goes to the city just mowing
down and they team up with all the gang
bangers and the gang bangers and the
Maga people come together and they fight
off the the Monsanto Pig Invasion
how much money do I need to make
something like that that would be an
amazing movie you guys know it New York
doesn't have enough guns you got a
million I mean if you're really good for
six million for the with the pigs though
unless we unless we did like really
crappy CGI pigs
I just saw um a pig trap where they they
get like these big cylindrical wire like
Gates that are hanging in the air and
then the 20 pigs go in like feral pigs
and they throw all this food in there
and all these pigs come in they start
eating the food and then the wire things
just drop and hit the ground and they
encase like 40 can trap like 40 hogs at
a time because the whole thing going out
there and killing them one by one is you
can't stop the spread of the pig because
they keep breeding the ones that survive
and we have a huge feral pig problem in
this country I'm sure a lot of the
listeners who who are from that part of
the world and every time there's an AR
story like no one should have an AR-15 I
go to Texas ranches and they're like if
I don't come out here every night with
my AR from this distance from my
protection and safety the only thing
strong enough to kill those and they do
amazing they kill cows we have a huge
feral pig problem in this country I
gotta pull up this story uh somebody in
the chat mentioned it and um I I is is
Ironman either right I saw this beyond
meat c-o-o arrested for biting man's
nose near Razorback Stadium
you go that long without it yeah you're
just so desperate for it you'll take
whatever you can get I know I also like
the idea we could do a movie where it's
like after not after eating nothing but
beyond meat you become a zombie you just
your brain is like I need meat and then
you just start eating people you do you
kind of do and you look at a lot of the
people who don't eat meat you know the
brain is largely fat for a reason there
there is you could tell you could
usually tell someone when when they're
on all vegan diet and there is a big
correlation with unhealthiness let's
just be real with each other let's be
let's be honest with each other we can
talk about pigs all we want but I think
the biggest attack Target always has
been cows cows are one of the most
nutritious one of the most amazing
animals on the face of the Earth Ian
loves them uh because of many different
reasons that I won't mention here I do
love cows but but cows also are linked
to the progression of humanity because
of the amino acids the macronutrients
and and just the amount of nutrition
that they provide human beings is
essential few decades ago the majority
of people had cows we no longer have
cows every family had a cow yeah every
family had a cow majority majority of
them yeah had a cow because they needed
there was a period where like I was
reading about it in the city like or in
the quote-unquote scenes they were
smaller every family had a couch yeah
and whether it's raw milk or beef liver
you can't underestimate the amount of
nutrition that they provide to the human
beings that beyond meat does not doesn't
even compare and we're also finding out
that a lot of the studies uh went beyond
meat being comparable in nutritional
value have been doctored have been
altered and have been faked you can't
you can't pay scientists off to come up
this is really fascinating about what
happened it says just after 10 pm an
officer saw the man shuffling and
groaning down the sidewalk with his leg
Twisted in the wrong direction he raised
his hands hands vertically and started
saying brains
it says the owner of the Subaru got out
and stated that Ramsay pulled him in
close and started punching his body
Ramsay also bit the owner's nose ripping
the flesh off the tip of his nose Jesus
oh man he really just wanted meat and he
couldn't take it anymore they like lock
he's I mean imagine what happens to your
psyche when you he's like no one was
forcing him per se to eat nothing but
beyond meat but as the CEO he had to
keep up appearances yeah so he like
shows up to a Burger King and he's like
I just want a burger and then someone
goes hey you're the guy from Beyond me
and he's like that's right I'll have the
Beyond Burger
he walks in a restaurant and then he's
like I'm just gonna get the filet mignon
and the guy goes hey I know you you're
from Beyond me we got your burger ready
to go just like you like it I guess your
salad when I was vegan for a few years
three or four years ago Luke kind of
what you were saying I I got my skin
started to tearing your rating I wasn't
getting enough B vitamins and I got
really angry I get really angry at
people eating animals I would be like
these blood suckers these mosquitoes
these vampires eating flesh sucking
blood I would get like how gross they
are like they need to Feast off of the
animal living like it was so weird
I I've made this point before but I just
got to say it in in lieu of you know
what what Ian was saying vegans are the
real bad guys no no no hold on
mind if you're vegan I don't mind if
you're carnitarian I don't care if
you're I'm uh omnitarian or whatever
you'd call it pescatarian pescetarian
well you know you eat fish and chicken
but you don't eat steak and mammal my
point is
this whole argument that people are bad
for eating mammals because they feel
pain I look at it this way
if you've got two guys one guy is
growing his own food and eating it and
one guy is ransacking and killing other
farmers and eating their crops which one
is the bad guy it's obvious the dude
who's going around and ransacking is the
bad guy we don't like him right we want
him to stop now think about animals and
plant life plants minding their own
business absorbing free and abundant
sunlight taking in rain water and only
what they get to grow and live their
beautiful lives and then Along Comes Is
boar that just destroys the plant just
annihilates it and the plant was minding
its own business and I'm like yo that
boar just killed that innocent thing and
did nothing wrong and those boars they
attack people too so you know what I'm
saying you should be killing and eating
these wild animals the plants are the
ones who deserve to live now you want to
eat fruit an animal okay we just gotta
make sure you plant the seeds afterwards
because that's the point of the fruit
but to destroy the plant that did no
harm and in no way negatively impacts
you you see deer deer are real villains
going around just eating all the green
like those trees didn't do anything to
anybody but those deer you gotta watch
out for them part of what you're saying
about replanting the seeds of what you
eat is concerning about the fish
population because I heard you guys
talking about that before I wasn't in
the room but that were maybe they
believe that we're running out of fish
that were overpopulated there's not
enough fish to feed the population but
there's this technology called iron
fertilization where they take iron dust
and they put it in the ocean and then it
creates Plankton the plankton eat the
iron it oxidizes and they eat it and
then all this Plankton Bloom appears and
that's food for fish and then all these
fish appear and you get these massive
Blooms of salmon off the northwest coast
of the U.S they did it a few years ago
people are like oh we gotta we gotta
hold back on this technology because it
might damage the environment dude iron
fertilization is the key and you can see
the river of blood in Antarctica is the
earth naturally fertilizing the ocean
with it's a river of iron it's this Red
Blood Red River just flowing in I
remember looking into this you're right
yeah you're absolutely right you can see
a glacier it'll break and then red water
because iron rich is preparing for the
flood because we're about to exit the
Ice Age and so it just gave me a really
good idea imagine this there's there's
there's this big cylindrical tube you
know a big tube and then it goes up to a
gigantic
what do you call it um what is it called
when you make those little terrariums
that are self-sustaining
um
biospheres but you can you can make your
own where you get like a little jar and
then you put certain things in and close
it and then the life will keep because
the humidity will come out and then
it'll terrarium yeah a terrarium imagine
you made a self-sustaining fish tube
that had everything in it so the fish
could grow and then it absorbed enough
to where you could actually like a
vending machine go up and put in five
bucks and then it spits a fish out for
you and that fish is gross and it's
totally automatic taking care of itself
and then you have fresh fish nobody
needs to go fishing we don't gotta run
out of fish yeah yeah no jellyfish to
worry about
hold the bag up and then it sprays the
fish and then you bring it home and then
you you cut it and you eat it boom
so cool we could streamline this whole
farming process you could try as long as
they're not eating their own feces
well it's got it gets recycled the
plants will do it and then you know oh
one thing I was thinking I was out of
the room but like at gas stations I
mentioned that if the power goes out you
can't pump gas do they have them set up
so that they use their own gasoline to
power generators so that you can
continue to pump every gas station I've
never seen a gas station not when the
power is out they they all have fossil
fuel redundancies because that's the
most essential thing that you need when
the power is out you need you need to
look you need gas you need to run your
diesel generator you need whatever I've
never seen a gas station like have no
power it could have happened but I think
the one of the main reasons nuclear is
illegal is not because of the danger
because batteries are dangerous the
Lithium-ion batteries that you remember
the note was exploding or whatever like
those are dangerous too if you puncture
lithium ion battery it's extremely
dangerous you can see it in water oh
yeah yeah yeah and and the crazy thing
is this is really crazy is you can buy
lithium batteries in airports and they
they oxidize when you expose lithium to
air it starts getting hot you put water
on it it bursts into flames it bursts
and Flames put it on a plane and and but
that's why they give you warnings when
you're going on planes you can't bring
lithium batteries in so I don't think I
I think the issue is you got people like
Bill Gates you know Bill Gates is a
a Luke how would you describe the the
moral uh a very Blossom big man
how would you judge him morally what how
do you describe him morally uh Mordor
Mordor no you've got people like him
here's the problem we've got Fusion
breakthroughs ignition right an ignition
was reached yeah basically this means
we're gonna have extremely cheap and
abundant energy if we get this process
streamlined because you know petroleum
is extremely energy dense nuclear is
extremely energy dense and fusion is
even better but that's bad news you know
why for Bill Gates because cheap free
energy means cheap free food it means
humans are going to be able to populate
expand and expand dramatically because
energy is being being provided extremely
cheaply here's how it started back in
the early days of humanity energy was
human energy you would eat stuff and
then you would do stuff and it was
extremely difficult then one day some
dude was like I don't want to carry
these these logs yo that big Critter
right there I'm gonna tie them up and
make him do it they just eat grass all
day so then we started we used animals
and converted and you know we use
animals convert food into you know to
move things convert our energy then we
discover we could burn stuff wood we
would use wood for fuel then coal burned
better than petroleum now we got nuclear
now we got Fusion all of these are
dramatic escalations and our energy
output minus energy cost so it's way
more difficult to cut a tree down and
then use the tree for fuel once you get
Fusion going you got crazy clean energy
for a long time yeah the people are
going to use it to power machines
they're going to use it to make food
they're going to have tons and tons of
babies and then we're going to have too
many people for Bill Gates
well they're all big population control
control freaks that's a huge part of of
the agenda no doubt but there was a on
Twitter earlier today I would love to
show you and pull up the chart but it
was the world population
population of the world from basically
as early as records go and you see the
spike at around 1880 and we started
drilling our first wells in 1880 and you
see the population and it's it's not a
it's not a curve it is just an absolute
it's flat and then it explodes and it
explodes because of fossil fuels and if
you are petrified of that and the people
who hate that the people who hate
population who want population control
they don't consider themselves to be the
peasants they consider themselves to be
the aristocracy and before then what was
there there were the super super rich
and everyone else served them and they
want to go back to that I honestly
believe that they don't want a middle
class that's that's arguing and and in
their way they want poor people who
serve and they want there it is there's
the chart thank you crazy look at the
population from literally the the first
commercial uh uh um oil well was was was
1888 I believe but just look how from
like 700 to 1800 the population barely
grows it's it's everyone who wants
reduced population considers themselves
the aristocracy just the way I always
say like when Bernie Sanders says he
wants to you know be a socialist it's
like well because you yourself you see
yourself as the party Elite you know you
don't see yourself as the peasant you
see yourself as the as the ruler also
the U.S barely grows what's causing this
dip now there's a dip this is the
projection uh Bill Gates oh okay you
think I'm kidding the dude gives TED
talks about how we need to have slow so
people need to understand Africa you
said Africa he said Africa needs to
control their population you say that uh
Bill Gates wants to reduce the
population they will tell you you're
conspiracy this and wrong what what Bill
Gates has that fact check is that we
want to slow population growth it's like
oh okay so what happens if you slow
population growth the older population
dies there's less younger people and you
see this chart the populations will
decrease because Generation X for
instance is larger than the millennial
generation well I think Millennials are
larger than the Gen X generation but
we're getting to the point now where the
generations are going to become even
then with slower population growth you
will come a point to where the older
generation dies in large numbers just
due to age and then the next generation
is smaller and population declines we'll
see this in China after the result of
their two child one child policy it's
going to take a little while still but
eventually their numbers will they're
they're plateauing right now but their
numbers will start to dip dramatically
absolutely and if you look at the
projections worldwide population is
going to go down dramatically to the
point where we are going to be facing a
civilization crash that's going to be
very severe and something that we might
even see in our lifetime because the
numbers are clear as day the populations
are going down dramatically and we're
seeing that in Japan what's happening in
Japan is going to hit the rest of the
Western World in a very severe way
that's going to have some very negative
consequences are they just slowing their
growth or are they actually losing net
numbers losing absolutely losing they
sell more adult diapers now in Japan
than they do baby diapers so yeah you
can tell CB on that that 60 Minutes
thing was geared towards 75 year olds
there's like an old an old segment dude
when I looked at this this dip I thought
okay what would cause a dip like that
starvation and War but then I realized
no those are the people that are going
to Mars they're just doing Earth's
population no no no that's what that dip
is those are colonists that leave well
there's a natural uh yeah natural
progression that that many scientists
are saying this will just naturally
happen on its own the population will
Peak and then decline naturally but now
with so many external factors with so
many choices when it comes to what's
happening in our society and our culture
with our diet that number is going to be
even far worse off as of course there's
propaganda on the corporate media
telling people don't have children it's
really bad for you it's bad for the
environment and people are listening to
that and deciding not to have children
which is one of the biggest best gifts
that you could have on the face of this
world so and again it's absolutely
mind-boggling to see this unfold right
in front of us and the population is
extremely declined in very dangerous
which is why the good people need to
have children good people need to have
children every time I say the lunatic
liberal couple who's like for the sake
of the climate we're not going to have
children I'm like good I don't want you
yahoos to reproduce anyway so I think
you're doing us all a service so but
those people who are good as one of them
is at the head of the table should have
as many kids as possible because the
good people should reproduce I saw you
tweeted out that you were like saw some
abused kid you know like I can't take
this anymore that made me so angry I
wanted what was that tweet do you
remember yeah I was on an airplane and
and this I hate to say anyone as as
trailer trash but trailer trash mom
um and you know I can't I ever I got a
lot of flack for people like you don't
know her backstory but like you can't
talk to a two-year-old like that this
was not like oh my God you're driving me
crazy this was and I can't say the words
because we're on YouTube but to like to
a two-year-old it was her own kids
because she had another one in her arm
and she was saying how much she doesn't
like them and then when the kid was
finally crying she just laid into him
and I I was like oh God and so we can't
have kids biologically
people that you know of I don't know or
is that exactly but you know that's a
big point of view I'm sorry we'll
probably we're probably trying to adopt
and I keep putting out feelers for like
if you have a kid and you know you're a
pro-life mom if you're a pro-life mom
and you're like I don't got pregnant but
it's a mistake and I'm in high school
Daniel Turner PTF on Twitter will pay
for everything and we'll get to keep the
baby though so
good people should have babies even if
they are of this you know this I
understand people's Hank but they should
have been and I hear you're going to be
feeding the baby fine steaks
wait if you give us two then like in a
few years we'll have a ton of land yes
but you just can't like have them I mean
you kind of you're gonna eat them but
they really shouldn't inbreed too much
so I can we can ah we can we can sell
you a boy and a girl who are not related
and you can eat all of their kids but
then save the girls and then and then
you swap out the RAM for another one and
then get the daughters pregnant
you can do it one generation you're not
really supposed to just like you know
you always need new Bloodlines
um you know even with chickens to a
certain extent like not not the eggs is
fine but if you're actually growing your
chicken population you shouldn't have
like roosters mate with their own that's
not good for them one of uh one of our
chickens went Broody and it's only like
seven months it's not the best so you're
gonna stop it when they go broody how
how they they pancake it yeah it's like
how did you get so fat and they just I
love I love Omega what do you do for the
lamb um when you're ready to eat them
um it depends upon weight how they're
have you know get them to the right
weight and then yeah we just it's kind
of sad because they know us so well and
they're so sweet and they are sheep
there's a reason why we call them sheep
and you just wave the little green
bucket and they get on the back of the
trailer and they eat and you just close
the door and
say and then drive them to the
slaughterhouse
no I don't I don't actually I bring them
to uh a place yeah a butcher abattoir I
think is the proper like fancy word but
it's but we use a very good Humane one
and you pay a little more for it and and
it's and it's fine do they March them
down and they put a bolt in their head I
don't know what they what they do is
they lock the sheep in a room and chain
their legs up and then psychologically
terrorize make them watch Clockwork
Orange
[Laughter]
what do they do they do a bolt to the
head right yeah yeah yeah
um yeah and the good ones do it with
that you know that the other sheep
aren't there you know so like you don't
see your brother get you know but I
understand sometimes you have to we do
have to feed a big population you want
to do the most humane way I think we're
but we're best off trying to get as much
food as possible from ourselves
absolutely we do you know but geez
anyone that has a reaction to thinking
putting a bolt in the back of a sheep's
head is like dude do you eat meat well
then get over it yeah you should know
yep yeah yeah so we got to start cycling
the chickens at some point the rooster
has got to go but yeah we gotta eat the
roosters there's too many of them
Roberto is safe Roberto is uh he's a
good dude they're all his kids he has
too many so he's he's going to retire
into old age and live a good rooster
life he's actually really small you know
when when he was the only rooster
he was big to us and then once his kids
grew up we went whoa the dude must been
a run they thought it was a girl yeah
you know we got some Jersey Giants by
the way we got we bought four turns out
one of them I think is a boy well I just
think it's great that you went to the
Frederick County Fair and looked at the
chickens and didn't tell anyone that
your chickens have been on billboards in
Times Square
it's so cute they're putting their
little chickens in a cage so we can come
see them my chicken was seen by like 3.5
million people I think per week that's
right Roberto Jr do you trade chickens
with other chicken Farmers I don't but
you do right yeah and you can usually
and this is where you know uh
um social media groups can be really
helpful so farmers are the most
Cooperative people in the world they're
the original socialists but the good
socialists right they do Swap and change
and if I have a ram and you have a ram
we need to change the bloodline a lot of
times it's just you know if it's the
same can you do like blood work on them
make sure they don't have diseases and
stuff before they get traded around is
that normal sometimes people do a whole
bunch of testing like that yeah but I
mean I honestly I've gone to people's
Farms
um for sale that I can just tell in a
couple seconds and there are lots of
things you can look at you can look at
their eyes you can hear their breathing
you can see their weight but you can see
in a person's Farm within five seconds
if their Farm is good or not we have two
uh barred Plymouth Rock chickens Vanessa
and Dorothy Vanessa's got a furled brow
she always looks really angry Dorothy's
eyes are big and round and she always
looks kind of goofy and then we have a
bunch of these rooster boys that came
from these two hens and you can tell
which one was the mom because they have
the same eyes it's like a bunch of the
boys are walking around with World brows
all angry and they're like young and
they're really aggressive and then the
other ones are like really much they're
much more docile and their eyes are big
and round and they're like walking
around I'll do feel like I love how they
all have different personalities yeah
they are every chicken does have a
different person I want to eat them
they're pretty funny but my brother
doesn't want to eat them he wants Nate
he wants he wants to let him fend for
themselves um do you have have you ever
processed like we can come do that with
you if you want it's it's a little gross
our our layers are so grossful and cut
their head off and then pull their
feathers out there's a big there's a big
cylinder the thing that def feathers
them it spins them around oh I we do it
by hand oh by hand really yeah there's a
machine I saw it steam blasts them and
then spins them around it rips all the
feathers on then you just pick it right
out yeah but the the the chickens the
hens they're still laying so no yeah
hold on you gotta keep them and then
what by the time they stop they stop
laying though it's like not as good
right and eggs are the greatest things I
love eggs I could eat eggs all the time
little vinegar and a little cream salt
uh what else you put in there oregano
Yeah you mentioned raw milk earlier and
I was surprised that you did because
it's highly illegal right the the way
the government cracks down on raw milk
fascinates me
um but but it's absolutely nonsensitive
it's insane yep it's insane I'm sorry I
don't interrupt but like with collecting
your own rain water but continue is it
because they're afraid of disease I I
don't understand what the Crackdown on
raw milk is it it makes absolutely no
sense at all the rainwater thing is
typically in more denser areas they just
don't want it to Fester bacteria and
stagnant water they they don't want it
to I forgot what it was but um
I was talking to a guy in the suburbs of
Jersey and he mentioned that if
everybody was collecting it it would
like limit runoff or something like that
and then you know I can't remember what
he said but it's not necessarily about
stopping you from having your own water
to drink it's about pollution and stuff
maybe something like what you were
saying we gotta go super chess if you
haven't already would you kindly smash
that like button subscribe to this
channel share the show with your friends
we've got a members only show coming up
at 11 p.m it's an update on a story
about uh we're gonna talk about this
teacher who has large oversized novelty
adult toys are they related to Bill
Gates maybe maybe I don't think so but
we'll talk about that and what and what
it means but we're going to read your
super chats now
grafty says bocus a fine actor was
snubbed only one line just saying I was
actually really impressed by that in the
uh in the episode last week when I think
Charles picks up bocus he yells yeah and
so we have it on camera I'm going yeah
he's like he's being picked away yeah it
was an excellent performance uh you know
because he didn't tell him what a great
uh what a great actor he is yeah
tuben bilubin says oh good name I don't
think Joe Biden lied about Taiwan my
friends who are MP and Air Force are
being deployed in less than two weeks
whoa what's happening in two weeks
great right before a midterm huh by
Raytheon stocks Everyone by Northrop
Grumman wow yeah I don't think he was
lying Biden has a statement I was
watching an old interview where he says
a president's approval rating goes up
during a crisis and then in this
interview he's like your approval
ratings got pelly's like is below 50
percent
if they're being deployed in two weeks
that's literally right before the
midterms what's crazy is if two
governments get together like Xi Jinping
and Joe Biden they're like we both need
to drum of some support let's create a
fake conflict so that everyone supports
us so was that when Biden said watch
what I'll do what did he what context
did he say I don't know that was during
the 60 Minutes interview the one out oh
really yeah I thought so the one about
when they were like what if Russia
deployed nuclear weapons he'd be like
the the reign of Hell God would come
down upon them he said something like
like that he didn't use cool words like
that but it was like we will annihilate
everything if they do that all right
real dark nylon hinnock says I have to
wear collared shirts at work can Tim
cast and we are change produce collared
shirts so we can look good at work and
support you at the same time oh sure why
not well Luke's the the more of the
T-shirt guy than me
now look into it
all right Leif Hagan says any updates on
reviewing the freedom phone or are you
guys scrapping that one saw Candace
Owens peddling them a few days ago cool
we never got it yeah
orders issuing it or issues ordering it
rather and the issue is this we can't
get orders from them because if we're
going to review them we can't have taken
special they could tamper with them not
saying they would but that's why it's
not legitimate and then um because we're
gonna do a Security review not just like
a function review and then the issue was
to buy it it would have to be bought
through like you know an individual that
they wouldn't know but it was backed up
like crazy it was just yeah and it was
giving me errors there was returning
errors on the website when I was trying
to buy them we tried for like two or
three weeks and then I just it just lost
the trail Mike Hillier says Ian you have
to take this opportunity Luke is giving
you I wish I had worked I wish I had a
workout friend you will enjoy the
benefits that's true yeah Ian it's true
but other people are like don't do it if
you don't want to do it like don't don't
let yourself get coerced into working
out because you think it'll be cool what
but I I agree I want to
you just you just did a Joe Biden
everyone should work out everyone yeah
but I mean I do isometrics like I I do
planks and it sounds like a scam I don't
do heavy weight training although I have
been working with the Kettlebell a
little bit lately yo I'm into the kick I
mean I'm into something yeah I'm into
Soldier Field because that's going to be
a lot of that stuff and it's going to be
just like good regular working out I
like that cardio yeah agility training
yeah all right Raymond g Stanley Junior
says Tim I failed I did the gas station
thing talk some good peeps but
registered zero I'm optimistic though
why you ask watch me long pause the
proof of the pudding is in the eating
you did not fail sir you did not fail
you went out you talked to people and
that's the first and most important step
when I used to work for non-profits they
would say outright the most important
thing you can do is talk to people you
are spreading those ideas you are
explaining it it will be in their mind
whether they're passionate about it or
not the first step is letting them know
about it there you go man
says tag team YouTube and Twitter about
the notification problem
uh tag team let's tag them it helps when
they get enough people tagging them okay
everybody
um you can try and tag at Team YouTube I
guess oh tag team YouTube oh there's a
tag team YouTube like team up together
against them yeah I noticed when I go to
YouTube I see the video in the queue 7
50 p.m there's a button that says notify
me when this goes live it's not the Bell
button it's not the subscriber I have to
go in and click it but if I don't do
that am I gonna get like I don't think
I'm gonna get a notification for it but
if it's not if it's not like in the
holding pattern until 10 minutes before
the show how do people click to notify
me now here's what I want to say
over the past week people weren't
getting notifications I don't know why
our uh video views on the clips were up
like 30 to 40 percent
way way up so our metrics were really
high on the live show however the
metrics were slightly down
and people weren't getting notified
about it so
this is why I can't stand about YouTube
is if they don't explain to you the
algorithm because their fear of people
people will exploit it then you tried
you you tried to say like right now
they're saying shorts is a big thing
like you should do shorts we want to
want to promote it and I'm like every
time YouTube's ever come to me and said
hey I remember when premieres came out
why don't you Premiere some of these
clips and I said no because you will
punish my channel what do you mean if we
do premieres we're going to change
everything disrupt our audience and then
your algorithm is going to punish our
Channel and reduce visibility because of
something you changed and then go
oh
well I don't think that'll happen and I
was like so what happens if people don't
react positively to premieres watch them
less or don't like getting jumping into
the middle of the video so they don't
watch it at all now our attention goes
way down and they're like yeah that
would hurt your channel yeah and I'm
like okay so I'm not using your new
weird things and hurting my and
confusing my audience and making
everything worse for me
all right Daniel nemes says my wife is a
nurse she's looking for a new job 95 of
the places she is looking at require the
jab when the efficacy is next to nothing
now Biden announces the pandemic is over
come on Luke
hmm Joe Figueroa says Tim has to be a
Bills fan who's what's the Bills Buffalo
Bills Buffalo Bills was that football
football is that football is that that's
what Drew Blitz is uh yeah I don't know
anything about football oh okay yeah no
ask me about skateboarding
I can explain to you what a switch
stance backside tail slide big flip out
is but I wouldn't begin to explain the
line of scrimmage
that's a thing right yeah that is yeah
very footballing when my friend when I
was a kid my friend was explaining the
rules and he said that I laughed I said
you're making that up and he's like no
I'm not I'm like you just made up a
gibberish or that's not real a line of
scrimmage I was like get out of here
with this and then I always just was
skateboarding
well all right all right I feel like I
have the butch all of a sudden wow holy
cow Wrath of ball says I don't think
it's a coincidence that Biden declares
the pandemic over six weeks before a big
midterm election yo if people are really
deploying out to the Pacific Theater
right before the midterms I would not be
surprised you make a good point she
hates Trump he doesn't like him he
didn't like what you know Biden is good
for Trump so if they came together and
said that one's good for she bite is
good Biden's good for sure yeah sorry
yeah Biden's good for she and she is
good for Biden so that I wouldn't be
surprised if they were like we're gonna
have a little Skirmish here wink wink
nudge nudge and she is jocking for
re-election again you're not supposed to
be a premier a third term but he wants
lifetime Premiership and so the
politburo the Central Committee Etc
um has to vote him in and so he is doing
a lot of things right now because he
wants to stay in power it's gonna happen
so so she's saying to Biden you help me
I help you everyone's happy
um makes perfect sense Biden's just like
come on man just drop a few bombs Amazon
and we'll come in we'll sweep it up
you'll look strong you know we'll go get
the votes um
Maybe
maybe but that would be a conspiracy who
knows those things don't happen no all
right
let's see what we got here
Johnny derp says Ian dismissed obesity
as a cause of death because it is a
comorbidity can anyone else think of an
illness a chew which itself was a
comorbidity
or I think with covet it was like 90
some odd percent of people who had
coveted and died had a comorbidity like
five comorbidities I think
there you go or there's a large
percentage of people that had like five
comorbidities or more Ola uh schulberg
I'm probably pronouncing it wrong
shubberg for the Friday show that was a
good one with uh that was Dr Drew right
yeah
he was great we went we played some
Blackjack afterwards that was fun oh
cool yeah oh this is a great story so uh
we went to casino right for the show and
we're playing Blackjack and there's this
guy he looks he's standing up and
playing and then he looks over and he
goes you look just like Anderson Cooper
and then he's like yeah I've heard that
and then the guy's like hey look they
got the table looks around he goes
That's Anderson Cooper isn't it and then
I look at him like that is not Anderson
Cooper and he goes That's Anderson
Cooper I know it is but then he keeps
playing and then you know maybe like 20
minutes of playing Drew's like all right
I'm gonna get out of here guys it's been
a blast thanks for having me get some
walks away and the guy goes that was
Anderson Cooper
it was Dr Drew and he goes who and then
the lady to his right she goes from MTV
and he went she goes love line he was
wasn't Anderson Cooper though I was like
Anderson Cooper's like a longer ahead
Anderson Cooper no longer ride you know
yeah Miss Mary says FYI no notification
received nothing in my recommend
recommended either I had to type in Tim
cast IRL in the search bar and find you
to listen to you that's crazy but you
know what
if so this is the power of of you know
when you have a when you have a show
people really do want to watch they will
try to suppress it our metrics are we're
behaving weirdly I don't want to say
they're down but they're just behaving
weirdly like one thing I'm noticing and
people watching might notices it'll be
like 35k viewers Spike to 40 and then 10
minutes later drop back down to 35 which
makes no sense that 5K people all at the
same time just decided to leave like
something weird's going on people not
getting notifications so I'll tell you
this if you want to support the show be
the notifications that's right you guys
can share the video for for those that
are big big fans that watch every
episode whenever the show starts take
the URL and just share it then that's
more powerful than notifications what
Mary is saying here is that she searched
for the show and then came to find it
that's basically give an old bop to the
head of YouTube being like even when you
suppress us people still come to watch
the show you can't do nothing about it
but we are doing our best uh if you go
to timcast.com the live players on the
front page now and we're trying to find
ways so that people who actually are
fans of the show will keep watching it
regardless of the algorithms in the
machine
all right RC J I uh what is this RC gym
r not Financial advice good graphene
stocks in
oh I have a cat I have a graphics you
got a few there's a company I'm working
with
um ecofeen I would highly recommend
checking these guys out there they're
studying pulling carbon dioxide out of
the air and converting it into graphene
that's going to be the future of making
it or one of the futures Big 12 sport
says what exactly does Tim want us to
why exactly does Tim want us to smash a
butt no and secondly what's a button now
it's a typo I wrote smash the like
button but I know went up so smash smash
the like button now if you haven't
already would you kindly smash the like
button now yes the butt now and then I
just thought I saw it after I went up
and I was like it is kind of funny so
you know we'll just let it we'll let it
go
all right Rosco P says Dairy Queen
chicken strip basket four or six piece
oh
what do you think six pieces of chicken
two contenders uh I opt for more because
then just store it and eat it later is
that the question chicken is the best I
like eat nothing but chicken I don't
like those boneless ones take over
chicken any day is it true that boneless
chicken is all genetically modified to
grow like in a vat without or just to
grow without bones so they have these
like chicken formed chickens that they
just Harvest what what are those things
have you ever had ever gone to a
restaurant actually you've been a KFC
yeah those drumsticks are insane
like what does that come from I I since
when I first got chickens I was like
there's no way that thing came from that
thing yeah so they have like the big
Mutant Chickens I guess yeah they're
probably genetically modifying chickens
and messing with their DNA so they're
fat or quicker and they have more heart
attacks and bigger and uh they grow a
lot faster than they usually did and
they're a lot bigger and they're
genetically not the same thing that they
were a couple days and all of our
chickens look like shop cheap shop
teachers from Canada yes right they have
yes absolutely what if they they
genetically modified chicken DNA to make
a big hunk of breast and dark meat with
like a central no central nervous system
just this respiratory system poor
creative so but it's not even a snow
brain what if they what if we
genetically engineered it just grows the
meat
um yeah I'd rather take we're not far
away I know genetically modified
chickens no but but I think we're closer
to plugging into the the
um the neural link metaverse and then
getting fed a tube of you know weird soy
protein but thinking it's chicken like
tasting chicken and seeing chicken while
you're eating it think about it this way
they could totally they could feed you
nothing but Cricket paste but you plug
in the neural link and then you see
filet mignon and when you're cutting it
kneading it it tastes like it but you're
actually eating Cricket paste that's a
bright future to look forward to I mean
I gotta I gotta be honest it is creepy
but imagine if you could plug in a
neural link and then modify your food to
be like Gordon Ramsay Elite five star
delicious perfect every time and you're
eating Soylent cubes we'll just put it
on our metaverse thing and pretend we're
not in this world and and look at our
metaverse hands and it's like oh look
I'm eating a steak and you're really
just eating Cricket but look yes but
they're they're you know it was a guy's
name Cipher in The Matrix the bad guy
yeah he made a point Joey pants he's in
The Matrix and he's eating a delicious
piece of steak in the real world it's
white paste which would you rather do
I'd rather eat something healthy that
tastes terrible but think it's good then
eat something unhealthy that tastes good
yeah I'm just saying we're probably
never gonna have that weird chicken
monster because we're gonna get rid of
all of this and everyone's going to eat
Cricket protein paste it's going to come
in Cubes but all that's going to happen
is you're going to put on some Wireless
brain modification thing and it's like
what do you want to eat today and
they're and the wife's gonna like shovel
like spatula the cubes on the plate and
then the kid's gonna be like I want
pizza and birthday cake enjoy whatever
you want and it goes beep and then it
turns into Pizza birthday cake mashed
and whatever nonsense and the husband is
like I believe I'll have fresh fresh
halibut and then he beep and then he's
there you go
defense eventually there's going to be
like people United for the protection of
crickets like there's no way they're
going to allow us to create all these
crickets and kill them someone will come
to the cricket party the cricket you
know Festival yeah all right ready to
rumble says I'm pretty fly for an old
guy Joe Biden that's right
Zach Williams says I no longer think of
being as old as myself than a fly is
what I think he meant due to flies not
thinking about how old they are you see
that that's I was thinking that first
like what what does a fly do is there is
there an idiom look
a lot of people mocked the the proof of
the pudding is in the eating and that's
actually the original idiot yes and a
lot of people didn't know that I didn't
know that yeah because we don't say that
because you know younger people just say
the proof is in the pudding it's because
you're stupid yeah because all young
people are stupid remember when Joe
Biden said he's been in office what 720
years or whatever remember when he had
cancer okay he told us 18 of his friends
did as well yeah yeah remember when he
got arrested freeing Nelson Mandela oh
wow
no remember when he said end of quote
repeat the line yes remember remember
what it cured cancer
OMG puppy says the Soviets built a
nuclear turbo jet engine that flew a
plane for several days without Landing
really
wow I mean if you think about it like
the nuclear material just gets hot it'll
boil water for a long time so what do
you really need
yeah I didn't know the Soviets either
that's awesome I know that you know uh
nuclear material will will boil water
that's how they do nuclear power nuclear
new turbines and everything they spin
them but I'm wondering like do you know
how nuclear submarine generates power is
that is that it's I wouldn't it's
probably steam in a turbo I think it
literally does the exact same thing as a
diesel engine would do but rather than
burning diesel it creates heat from the
nuclear reactor but it would need to use
it would expand water right so like
diesel explodes so the expansion can
cause we got the General Electric j87
nuclear powered turbo jet engine the
aircraft nuclear propulsion program and
preceding nuclear energy for the
propulsion of aircraft project were
developed in 1946 by the Air Force the
United States Air Force uh bet so if
that's what wow 70 years ago almost I
can't imagine that they don't have that
technology available for modern cars I
mean all of our planes should be using
that everything should be using I guess
the problem is if it gets shot down they
don't want the enemy to get the nuclear
generator and then reverse engineer the
plans or something that's the idea yeah
maybe John Gagner says that's literally
an episode of China Illinois the hog
episode is so hilarious well we just
came up with an original idea to do a
horror movie about paper
the pigs cometh he's thinking about that
Winnie the Pooh did you see the Winnie
the Pooh Blood and Honey yeah yeah
piglet they're tusks are vicious you get
those feral pigs with the tusks you
could have some really gory scenes
people die all the time here we go
stronger than Stones as a sheriff in
Texas opened an investigation into Ron
DeSantis for the Martha's Vineyard thing
today just proves there's a civil war
yeah and also Rhonda said it's got a
standing ovation over the Martha's
Vineyard thing broke fundraising yeah
he's got he raised like 177 million I
think so uh I think dude's gonna run for
president
should I mean the Martha's Vineyard
thing I just really I I see a lot in
DeSantis that he's done so much better
than Trump has especially the Martha's
Vineyard thing I think he should
immediately do it again oh yeah do more
all right let's see what we got here
Katie Jinx says since Dan is here I want
to comment that the nation's largest
nuclear power plant is in the middle of
the Arizona desert States like
California have no excuse
yeah put in the middle of the desert put
in a mountain or something you know put
in your back everyone should have one
every we should be building nuclear
power plants left and right instead we
gave 80 billion dollars to Ukraine so
your company power for the future you're
more interested in just literally
creating sustainable power than you are
in one in particular we're we're about
protecting American Energy Independence
so it's primarily fossil fuels I got
nothing wrong with nuclear but you know
just the conversation we were having
earlier the fossil fuels run our country
they run our freedom really and the more
we get rid of them because we're going
to quote unquote go green the more we're
surrendering our our agency and we're
surrendering it to the government or
we're surrendering it to China fossil
fuels are pure freedom and that's what
we advocate for all right Publius
Valerius publicola says Fusion is never
going to work I don't like Bill Gates he
has a reactor design that consumes
nuclear fuel waste of course he is
withholding it till the economy has
crippled solely for profit well he's
working with China on that specific
project and he had to move it because of
um I forgot the exact reason is as well
but he's doing a lot of research and
development with the Chinese government
which should concern a lot of people
because you know again the technology is
going to be in their hands and they're
going to use it for their own political
purposes this company called Terra Power
American nuclear reactor design and
development engineering company in
Bellevue Washington Bill Gates home
state business from Washington this is
an important one Hal Edward says
white-tailed deer are rats with hooves
like that do they have hooves they have
something else though don't they it's
like a hoof but it's like kind of
different they're just not isn't it I
think they're not what clothing like
cows yeah yeah I don't know we have a
family of deer that live right in front
of the house and they're always coming
out trespassing and eating my plants
they eat everything and I and I yell at
him and shake my fist and they just
stare at me and keep eating we were on
the fourth of July a family of the Year
came out on freedomastan and just
watched and ate as things were blowing
up they did not care at all but uh
recently sad story Bambi died oh uh
don't know but one day we came home and
there were like 50 vultures all over the
property oh big ones just everywhere and
then I saw where they were hanging out
cruised over on my little bike and sure
enough there was a baby deer that had
died oh don't know exactly how but they
annihilated that thing and now it's gone
my drive home takes twice as long as my
drive here because it's dark when I
leave and it's it's just deer dodging
it's just non-stop it's all back roads
and it's just non-stop deer and when
it's raining it's worse because you get
all the possums it's like it's like a
video game just dodging creatures
it might say 35 miles an hour you go 20.
I won't go into like like traffic don't
get me wrong like just I'll just go yeah
when I leave here after the show every
night there's just like seven or eight
deer just like everywhere all over the
property and they just stare at you
because they're really dumb and it
cracks me up that we have like a year
hunting season you should be able to
hunt deer all the damn time you know so
many deer I wanna can we train them
though like can you train the deer
because I'm wondering if we can get them
to do something functional for us you
know like if we can if we can train them
I'm thinking we can uh you know time up
and then have them spin a turbine for us
oh yeah well sure that's the original
the original Power as well right how can
we get our deer to generate energy for
us as they Mill about and do nothing but
eating crack great question you know I
looked up can you train deer and it just
keeps saying can you train a dog to
track deer can you train a dog I got it
and train a dog they're pretty delicious
a treadmill
hamster wheel lock them in yeah but but
as they walk food slowly comes out and
so we just need to the cost of energy
they generate to be more valuable than
the cost of the food we give them and I
think we can do it yes you've got to
withhold the food so that they're
constantly trying to get it but they
have to eventually I'm thinking like a
world economic Forum agent they never
actually get the food stop it Ian no
sorry isn't it here's an important one
it's Justin Amy uh I'm me Amy Says
unless they change copyright laws again
Mickey Mouse character will be public
domain in 2024 Disney lobbied to change
the copyright laws to the current law
last time Mickey Mouse the pig Slayer
he'd be the protagonist in the movie uh
the swine all I know is if Mickey Mouse
goes public domain yo it's gonna be lit
I'm gonna make crazy Mickey stuff anime
Mickey drug dealer Mickey Breaking Bad
Mickey how did South Park get away with
all their Mickey Mouse episodes
yeah so it's like the only the only
thing that changes that you're allowed
to make legitimate standard Mickey Mouse
stuff okay so you could actually just
make you know steamboat Mickey and they
it's like public domains they're they're
Mickey covet episode was brilliant I
loved it and I love that he was like he
was like so hardcore pro-china he speaks
Chinese
accent oh it was great just great
all right Tina Collette says you are on
the same time every day I just tune in
at 6 p.m Mountain I don't miss a show
nice and there's a butt there but I
don't know there's something else when
did you start doing Clips because some
people are explaining that it's because
of the clips we've always done Clips
okay since on this channel or a separate
Channel this channel no not always yep
it was like only like always eight
months wasn't it nope always some people
are saying that YouTube gives you only
three notifications per 24 hours and
that the notifications are going out for
the clips but not the live stream and
that's probably true because our Clips
have started doing way way better
exactly so what likely happened is that
because didn't you have a Clips Channel
I think you just figured it out I think
some people have Eclipse Channel that's
why I changed we didn't always put our
full-length episodes up on the channel
that's the only thing wait what's
changed we did not always have our
full-length episodes visible yeah but
that was only a couple of months right
exactly they were coming up unlisted in
the beginning and then we put them on
and now we put them on a playlist so you
think Eclipse channel is better than
well I know YouTube only gives you three
notifications in 24 hours right I think
that's it if there's Clips or if there's
other things going out to the to the to
the you know audience shorts or whatever
then the the regular channels not being
uh yeah I'm telling you everyone's like
YouTube's prioritizing shorts and I'm
like you it's probably a bad idea so we
did we did create a Tim cast Clips
Channel needs a new channel it is a new
channel timcast clips and it's got a
small Tim cast collapse is a new channel
that's been around for like a year now
where we put Clips on it uh yes I'm
talking about like the new things yeah
yeah I I think and I don't even know if
we should even bother with him at this
point it's about a week old but like
you're saying I think it's I think it's
muting the notifications for people
because no the muting was happening
before this before short just for the
just for the sh um for the things
nothing I gotta use the right one and I
want to clarify too that when this when
this weird thing did happen the the
website broke as well so something
changed on YouTube's end you know
whatever
but uh good uh if the clips go out
that's great the clips are basically uh
it's it's actually here's how it works
if we do a live show most people who
like the live show will will come and
watch the live show regularly
we the titles of the live show are the
biggest story that we have today it's
Biden declare's pandemic is over in 60
minutes uh on 60 Minutes there's a good
amount of people that will see this and
say I don't normally watch that show but
that story is interesting and they'll
click it
in this whole show we've talked about a
variety of subjects some people might
say I don't care to watch the show and I
don't care to learn about biting the
pandemic but we have a segment about the
Ford truck or Dodge truck being
discontinued that clip will likely to
get clicked so by breaking up an eclipse
you have a combination of some people
will watch certain clips and not the
full show and so it maximizes the amount
of reach and interest and everything is
there a setting when you uh upload a
video to have it not send out a
notification yes but you don't want to
do that if you just want to do three a
day like focus on the main show in two
clips the the fact that our viewership
was way way up but our live viewership
was slightly down and not even slightly
down it's not necessarily the issue it's
like all in all it's still just good for
the show the goal is the the clips will
attract new audience members the people
who like the show no one to come and
watch the show so I'm not super worried
about the notifications moral of the
story set your own notification be the
notification find yourself yeah tell
your friends hey are you watching Tim
cast IRL the greatest show in all I've
tweeted out every day and on mines I
posted on mines every day before we go
live shout out to the wind all right all
right all right if you haven't already
would you kindly smash that like button
subscribe to this channel share the show
with your friends become a member at
timcast.com because that's where the
uncensored Shenanigans happens Monday
through Thursday 11 pm you can follow
the show at timcast IRL and follow it
everywhere you can follow me personally
at timcast we do have Eclipse channel
it's called Tim cast Clips I don't think
we've ever actually shouted out one time
no but but so the idea was we want to
use the clips on the channel to
naturally find its algorithmic push so
like YouTube will be like here's who
likes this and then it will be a
separate way to to you know find new
people the ultimately I'll put it this
way YouTube silos you after a certain
amount of time they say okay this group
of people likes this Channel and that's
it so you you have different channels
and different promotion to try and find
different areas so follow me on Twitter
at timcast and everywhere else and of
course I have my other channels
youtube.com timcast and timcast news
Daniel do you want to shout anything out
yeah Daniel trying to powerthefuture
part of the future.com always good to be
here you can follow me Daniel Turner PTF
on all platforms and as always the
Shameless plug for the greatest Virginia
sheep Farmers Bristol Farm Virginia on
Instagram Bristol Farm Virginia follow
your favorite we got it we gotta swing
by me make a couple weeks yeah we got
pumpkins or something I I no I don't
grow any I don't grow anything uh any
vegetables we just just raise animals I
don't wanna I don't want to hurt the
innocent vegetables anyway
those ransacking animals who just
destroy you know I've been pulling for
cows on the property so much I could I
could buy one uh but just someone here
has to take care of it but anyway my
YouTube channel is youtube.com forward
slash we are change you can see my
adoration for cows especially on Luke
uncensored.com I talk about them all the
time I think they're fascinating amazing
beautiful animals and
um I'm not gonna say what I was gonna
say what are you gonna say Luke for the
after show are you gonna work out with
me yes are you gonna work out
in the in this and from there the cows
well put in your finger you want to put
your finger in a cow's mouth no no no no
no I'm not going there I'm going down
the pathway that that has oh yeah
probably helped civilization progress
that's to the poop oh because they poop
and then psilocybin mushrooms
that's why they Revere them in India and
ancient culture the Brahma exactly
because they would eat the mushrooms
they would trip balls they would do yoga
then they would smoke Opium you know
they did all sorts of crazy stuff back
in the day hey check these out well
check this out these are this is cloud
Schwab's book and this is my book just
want to show you how similar they are in
that weird but uh if you'd like to get
deep inside my mind on your own time
check out my book it's on Amazon writing
in the dark by Ian Crossland I'm just
imagining like people are like I I
really do want to understand Ian's mind
and then like they picked the book up in
the first page and then five minutes
later the books at the end and their
hairs on them yeah it's an easy read
it's only like 70 Pages more of a
manuscript of psychosis so have fun with
it I love you guys follow me at Ian
Crossland I'll see you around
um that's quite the selling point for a
book for sure now I wish I had a book to
Hawk also you guys can follow me on
Twitter which is almost as good as books
at Sour Patch let's as well as minds.com
and also on Sour Patch let's stop me we
will see all of you over at timcast.com
in the member segment which is gonna get
oh boy spicy I guess because this story
just won't stop and it's getting crazy
and there's so much going on so smash
that like button on the way on your way
out and we'll see you all over at
timcast.com in about uh 45 minutes
Vegas